it's scheduled for 10 30.
february 7th
yes
that's monday of the week of the
deadline
to give give you some time to make sure
you have your committee reports it's
to repeat if anybody is not going to be
available on the 7th
which is the monday of our deadline and
when we are going to exec
all the remaining early bills
please let me know as soon as possible
they were showing february 8 when i
checked them so
i will recheck but thank you for letting
sure it's uh it's been known to happen
february 7th monday
if you can't if you can't make it let me
that's why that's why i'm reminding you
now
so that there's time to make
arrangements
i mean we could exact as well
okay
being ten ten o'clock i'm opening the
hearing on house bill 1059 and i call
the sponsor representative fellows
thank you madam chair
this is sally representative sally
fellows from holderness
this bill deals with issuing licenses
and i filed this bill at the request of
director
courtney from oplc so i will turn it
over to her to
answer any questions
thank you representative fellows
good morning madam chair members of the
committee um my name is lindsay courtney
executive director office of
professional life insurance
certification
this bill is
very important for public safety
purposes
right now many of our boards currently
lack a quorum despite our best efforts
to find qualified individuals to serve
and many of these boards have not
delegated authority for the agency to
issue licenses
and
i would submit that no board has the
authority to presently to delegate
authority to deny licenses
we're also um
so essentially with with those boards
that currently lack a quorum
we are issuing licenses by operation of
law pursuant to rsa 541 a29
541a29 requires an agency to respond to
an application within 30 days of
receiving the application
once we receive a response it doesn't
necessarily need to be the response
needed
the agency has 60 days to act
and the agency
that i'm discussing is is our licensing
boards
so what happens when the board does not
convene a quorum to adjudicate the
application after 60 days the
application is
is granted by operation of law without
regard to whether or not the individual
actually meets the requirements for
licensure obviously this this poses some
significant
safety concerns
i'll give you an example for about two
years the
board of hearing care providers which
has now been merged with speech language
pathology did not have a quorum
so it was a great time for somebody who
was unqualified to apply to become an
audiologist
because we were just required to issue
the licenses
even if they did not meet the basic
requirements so this bill really just
clarifies that if the person does not
meet the requirements for licensure that
the agency does have authority to deny
it
be happy to take any questions
thank you
i take it that your
review of the requirements is things
like education and not
good moral court character or some of
the less
obvious requirements some of the boards
have
correct my personal opinion is i i do
not like good moral character
requirements because i think it invites
subjectivity and bias into the licensure
application process um we obviously
would not be able to adjudicate that so
we would just be looking at whether or
not they've met educational
qualifications our supervised training
you know whatever the statutory basic
anna pearson
thank you madam chair uh to bounce off
the
our chairman's question here um when you
look at
the requirements that are not subjective
does criminal background
fall under that as something you look at
so we don't have someone coming in here
from another state slipping under the
radar who's got a rap sheet
taller than you
so the problem with criminal background
checks is that um unless it's
the state can't categorically and i
should say criminal history checks the
state can't categorically i think it's
under rsa 332g
say if you've been convicted of x you
don't qualify
um
that is set forth in statute so there
needs to be a board that or an entity
that has a certain amount of discretion
to determine whether or not they meet
good moral character requirements
unless the board had previously put into
place some sort of matrix
or standing order permitting us or
letting us know
who would um be qualified um
after having a criminal history check i
don't think this bill would also allow
us to deny licensure based on past
criminal history because it's not clear
in the statute
who would qualify if you have a criminal
history
okay we'll follow up
thank you madam chair the
specifically what's coming to mind with
me is the ability to teach in the state
of new hampshire
has a fairly substantial paragraph on
certain criteria that will deny someone
the ability to have a teaching license
do we not have that
in other boards
i know you don't deal with teachers but
but from the oplc standpoint
do we not have
does this not found in any of the 54
boards it is not found in most of the
boards because the boards have the
discretion to review the criminal
background check
so
yeah so that the only thing that oplc
could do is say yes you have given us
your fingerprints and applied for the
check
that they can deny the license if you
haven't done that
right
right now we're not allowed to deny any
licenses so i think this is a step in
the right direction um
but it certainly it doesn't resolve some
thank you uh this is sort of related and
that is um
you know do any of the boards or finding
the licenses are there
other requirements which are
discretionary or unclear or the boards
normally would need to get involved in
making a decision what sort of other
requirements like that might there be
so it always depends on the board
because each board um and it also
depends on the statutory framework right
so certain
practice acts
grant to certain licensing boards carp
launch authority to come up with all of
these additional requirements i think
the board of psychology is one of them
certain practice acts have specific
statutory requirements and they must
stay within the balance of those
statutory requirements
we have strongly encouraged boards to
eliminate subjective requirements to the
extent possible
case studies those types of things oral
interviews
the governor
actually issued an executive order back
in 2019
directing boards to
review their processes and eliminate
subjective requirements
so we strongly encourage that but
certain boards still have subjective
requirements and obviously i'm not
qualified to assess
uh an essay of a psychologist to
determine you know
whether that person is a great
psychologist which is why we might we
much prefer exams that are based on
objective criteria accordingly so um to
answer your question there are
subjective requirements that we would
not be permitted qualified to review
follow up so does that mean that um you
know for any of the licenses where there
are such subjective requirements you
wouldn't do anything with it and you
would you know if they met the other
objective requirements they would get
the license under this is that your
understanding that's correct okay thank
you
representative bailey
hi
when the licenses have been auto
automatically rejected for lack of a
board meeting
do they at least get their license fee
back
no licenses are not rejected for lack of
a board meeting they're automatically
approved even if the individual doesn't
meet the qualifications
thank you and no we don't return the the
fee
corrected
actually if if you're applying for a
license and the board
delays the meeting you
you're still on the hook for
for the fee although we'll apply for
your first for your first license
representative show up
thank you madam chair good morning
lindsay
excuse me miss courtney uh can you give
us an idea is this
instance that you're referring to where
boards couldn't meet
an approximate percentage of the boards
that this affected was it half was it
mostly all or
it varies i will say there are a handful
of boards that currently lack a quorum
um
an example of medical technicians they
haven't met since february
the board of respiratory care
practitioners i don't even know when the
last time they met
so we're just issuing licenses after 60
days the problem with that also is that
they've got to wait 60 days to get their
license and as you can appreciate in
covid 60 days is a long time for a
respiratory care practitioner to wait
for a license but that's you know kind
of a separate issue
so there are a handful wards that are
just not meeting then there are boards
that particularly in the healthcare
because they are actively working in the
profession
um
that they'll cancel at the last minute
and there may be you know like
psychology for example had to cancel
their december meetings somebody had to
wait two months to get a license that
sort of thing so they are consistently
meeting but there could be
there could be times where people fall
thank you um
i'm sure you're aware that uh some of
the boards that you have proposed to
members of this committee to make
advisory
and
i'm sure you're aware i've inserted
language in several of them saying
in consultation with the board for
certain actions
do you feel that that language would
enable you to consult with say one
member of that board to approve such
applications
yes so that's what we do with our
current advisory boards body art massage
reflexology we've established uh
criteria that it's it's objective and
clear
so that staff know what they're looking
for and there are any criminal history
checks for those professions but to the
extent that there are questions we
consult we consult with our advisory
board members
thank you
representative lackas
thank you um
so is this problem the board's not
having quorum not meeting is something
new maybe related to covid or has this
been a long-standing issue
um i think i think it's been exacerbated
certainly particularly in our health
boards we're struggling we've sent out
email blasts you know i've i've reached
out to stakeholders we're struggling to
get people to be able to take time off
work to come drive to concord and
um
and so that so we have seen that
exacerbated during covet i don't see it
really getting any better to be honest
with you um
given our healthcare workforce shortage
right now it's just hard for employers
to give employees time off what we're
finding is we get a lot of people who
have retired
who may be interested
which is great at the same time
depending on how long it's been since
they've actively practiced you may not
be getting that
perspective that you'd like
okay follow-up
so outside the healthcare area i mean
are there other boards where this has
been a
you know an issue prior to covet and
continues to be
um
yes uh court reporters is another one i
think you'll see a bill later they have
two members they're currently not
meeting um
we've offered to meet outside with them
they are not meeting but there's only 60
people in that profession so
i don't know that will ever convene a
quorum um of that board
um the technical boards seem to be doing
better as it relates to a quorum they
also tend to be a little bit smaller
some of our health boards are really
large
but yeah i would agree that cobain has
certainly exacerbated this problem
thank you
president marcia than goalie
yes thank you madam chairman and thank
you for taking my question i'm wondering
if these various boards were able to
meet during the state of emergency when
remote meetings were allowed and would
adopting a hybrid model where you could
have a
physical meeting placement members could
attend remotely would that solve your
problem
um i think it would solve uh problems
for
for most
there are boards that literally lack a
core of medical technicians is one
um and they only have two members which
is not a quorum and we've just received
word that the other member
plans to resign so for most boards i
think that would certainly
help um we so most of our all of our
boards went remote uh pursuant to the
governor's emergency order may 7th we
brought them back in
and we did
we did obviously observe that there were
issues with
thank you madam chair
and
i understand the difficulty it's a small
state and
some folks could have to travel an hour
and a half two hours to get to a meeting
and a board they
have
been put on
um
would it help
to
make it
mandatory that
those that have been put in positions
have to attend a certain percentage of
meetings
and how about
making it a requirement that they meet
so many times a year so that we can get
this done and if they don't show up for
those meetings that they will be
replaced and
and then the other thing in talking a
few members here
maybe
i know a lot of places have alternates
on boards that could fill in um to make
sure they get that quorum
i'm just thinking of a few things we
could do to help out because i think
instead of making everything advisory we
should try and solve the problem we have
of not getting quorums
and looking at the best way to get there
is what i'm looking for
yeah i think that would um
i would
i would support that i think part of the
issue is actually getting people to
volunteer their time um that is it we
have a number of vacancies i send
reports to the governor's office every
other week and
there we have a ton of vacancies
actually
public members are very difficult to
come by
i think part of the issue right that
we're dealing with at the office is that
for example
you know i'm an agency head all agency
heads have to sign a power of attorney
so that if you know something happens or
you basically
the agency the government can still
function
no no there there is no such uh
contingency plan when these boards can't
meet for whatever reason and some of it
is justifiable um of course
so when a board doesn't meet literally
that part of government shuts down um
what is the state's contingency plan
the government the governor doesn't have
authority i mean to just go in and
license people i suppose the legislature
could convene quickly but what we're
dealing with right now is a lack of a
contingency plan
maybe the contingency plan could be
alternates i think it would depend on
whether or not the state feels that
that's sufficient
my main concern would be that in certain
professions we're just struggling to
maybe our boards are too large i don't
know i don't know i mean when you have
to have eight people to convene a quorum
that seems
seems a little large
that seems reasonable representative
road and then pearson
thank you madam chair miss courtney
would you be able to give us a list of
the boards and how many members are on
the board
to make a quorum
and the last date that they met
that way we have
follow-up
and what do other small states do
it
yeah licensure varies i will say vermont
has moved to an advisory model
the majority of their professions are
under advisory boards the secretary of
state has direct authority to issue
licenses there are but each
state has taken a different approach
there's about 22 umbrella agencies
and then other states
larger states
have licensing boards
some states
the umbrella agency there are no boards
i think utah is one of them and the
state just directly regulates the
profession through i think their
department of labor so it really varies
follow up
so might it be possible for you to put
together a list of contingencies based
on what other states do that would fit
our model
possible contingency plans correct yep i
can do that and last follow-up i'm sorry
one more i'm going back to the um
criminal
i'm sorry
my final follow-up
um
i'm concerned about this um
lack of ability to use criminal record
so how can we address that because that
seems
an emergency to me
so how do we how can we address that
what are your recommendations for that
i think it depends on the board i think
when you look at for example
um i believe medical technicians which i
think we're the only state to regulate
medical technicians but i think i
believe we require criminal history
check for them
so
um
you know one response would be to just
continue to try to find people to serve
on the board to review the criminal
background checks the other option could
be
explicitly set forth
you know
statute although you'd have to look at
whether that conflicts with 332g as to
who would actually qualify and who would
not 332g directs us to review a
case-by-case analysis because
under 332g
the right to pursue an occupation is a
fundamental right so it doesn't give us
the ability to just carve out
classifications of people who are
qualified but
assuming the legislature can change
three theta to g and wanted to do that
you could certainly have
um
certain buckets and then the other
option is to have a contingency plan so
that another regulating body can
actually act
thank you
alexander pearson
thank you madam chair
we've had a lot of discussion here
in the last 10 minutes in reference to
boards
in their quorum abilities with the
actual legislation we're talking about
in front of us 1059 do you see any
differentiation here between a board's
inability to
have members
to make a quorum versus a board's
refusal to meet
as far as this legislation goes or the
do you read this as being the same
irrelevant to the the purpose just the
fact is the board is not meeting
correct i mean we have some people who
refuse to come into the building and
then we have some people that for
what i would consider to be justifiable
reasons just can't come
and then we have some i can't
there literally is not a quorum
it doesn't matter under this bill this
bill is really just intended to provide
a contingency plan if a board is not
meeting that would allow the agency to
deny licenses to people who are clearly
not meeting the qualifications because
we have concerns that we've been
essentially handing them out like candy
representative o'brien
thank you madam chairman thank you for
taking the question
i understand what you're trying to do
here and not so much against it but just
concerned
if somebody i know you have trouble with
getting people there but what happens
when somebody objects to the licensee
and what is the procedure
can they submit an affidavit or a report
they'll be read into the record for the
consideration of the others
in
in context of how this will work in the
future
so
when you say if somebody objects who it
objects
well
you get somebody applying for the
license let's say you make somebody is
familiar with that particular licensee's
case
and they cannot make the meeting is
there a way that they can submit if they
cannot make the meeting submit some form
of
objection
so certainly our
even when we lack a quorum um and i'll
give you a true example
we had on i think it was
land surveyors recently
um they missed a meeting or two and
there was an applicant who was held up
in the 60-day time frame and we
they
got the license by operation of law or
we told the we told members of the board
that you know you need to come in or
this is going to happen
we had
concerns from a board member that the
person didn't meet the basic
qualifications
under the current structure
it didn't matter
we had to issue the license because
there was no quorum
under this structure
we could take the feedback and provided
that the concerns were they clearly
don't meet this
requirement set forth in statute or rule
we could deny the license if it was just
i know this person i don't think they
would have good moral character i i'm
not sure that absent a specific
authorization by statute that we would
a follow-up follow-up uh i i think what
i was probably thinking about you're
doing the medical and emts in particular
and so when they come for re-licensing
and everything they do have a history
and what happens if one community did
have some objection in just following
along that line
it's a valid point i think it goes
probably less to licensure and more to
disciplinary so the other issue that
this doesn't address but the other issue
is when boards don't convene a quorum
there's nobody to review complaints and
we have we do have some boards right now
with just complaints out there that um
there's nothing we can do about it
thank you
i have a question assuming that somebody
applied for meeting and a board
applied for an app a license immediately
after one board meeting they're
scheduled to meet every month there's a
snowstorm in in the month and the 60 day
is the day before the
the next meeting of the board
and so therefore you wish issue the
license on day 60 the board meets looks
do they have recourse to review the
license and say uh wait a minute this
person does not meet our qualifications
or do they have to go into the
disciplinary mode they do because once
you have a license you have a
constitutionally protected property
interest that entitles a person to due
process notice and an opportunity to be
heard before you take it away
all right thank you very much other
other questions from the committee
representative
thank you madam chair so i i can imagine
you're
also thinking in the background
something that just has been occurring
to me as i listen to the director
testify that is those of us who are on
the jail car realize that that we also
have a problem uh with rules uh which
sometimes can expire uh the joke the
jail car is not
entitled to kind of pocket veto rules if
we if we don't act
within the specified
deadline unless we
get a waiver
the rule goes into effect
uh and so
and we've had situations that chair i'm
sure is aware of it
in as much as she's been on the jail car
with me for the last 10 years or so uh
that we we have situations where rules
come in and and uh they get vetted they
go back to the board for
for uh
some kind of amendment because the rules
a certain aspect of the rule is uh uh is
not acceptable to the jail car
and and it sits there because the board
is not going to meet again for x number
of times so if you have quorum problems
then they never get around to it no but
i i'm raising this with the chair
because is this something where we may
want to uh amend this bill a little bit
to uh
uh to try to expand it
to
to consider some of the
schmidt that's a very valuable point but
it's more appropriate for an executive
session
well but uh she is the director of
an organization that has a very large
number of small boards
director carl if you can't understand
what the question was
represent schmidt if you could put it
more concisely
would you uh based on your experience
with your boards uh would you uh
consider that there's some aspect of
this bill which you would recommend
expanding to facilitate
the rule writing aspect along with the
other stuff
that we've been talking about
yes i would consider that i think that
uh
some concerns i would have is that
we would receive a lot of objection to
that um
it is a valid concern court reporters
for example is in the middle of
rulemaking and
staff were trying to get them to convene
a quorum in a parking lot so that they
could vote on something and they and
they're not so the rules are just at a
standstill and then when they expire you
know the agency can't do anything to
enforce the rules
the proble i think what i think what
you're getting at though is there are a
lot of issues here uh there's issues
with occupational licensing that touches
upon
the structure that we have decided as a
state to utilize
i the current structure is not working
i'll tell you that right now i don't
know what the structure should be
but i think maybe that should be a
larger conversation
um
i would have concerns attaching it to
the bill because i think that the bill
probably wouldn't move forward
and we have a significant issue right
now where we're statutorily mandated to
issue licenses to individuals who
clearly lack qualifications for those
licenses and i just i want i would like
to get that resolved
but i mean i i would certainly support a
larger
discussion obviously or as to what we
should be doing with occupational
licensing
so uh
the aspect that we're now discussing is
one that occurred to me uh and i
wouldn't want to sink this bill by
making it too too much of a christmas
tree but to the degree that we
included a study committee that's pretty
unobjectionable as in terms of burdening
the bill
representative schmidt we have a
good number of other licensing bills
some of which are rather broad and we
can consider that issue in the context
of those bills i'm glad to hear that
since i i was wondering whether we had
other vehicles we certainly do okay
thank you representative pearson did you
have a question no i just um it's more
along the lines of i agree with the
director here that let's not jeopardize
1059 for the sake of of a broader
um
deep dive that clearly needs to occur
here
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1059
representative infantine
it's
it's an occupational injury no question
about it
madam chair and committee
my name is representative will infantine
from hillsboro 13.
i am also a member of the new hampshire
electricians board
and as i signed in
madam chair whether i'm opposed or in
support i wrote not sure
next to it
i would like to
just explain a few of the things
that were asked by your committee
members here
just in relation to the electrician's
board
we have always had a full board we've
had a full board for 10 or 15 years we
did not miss one meeting through covet
we met pretty much every month
or every other month as needed
first via zoom and then
one of the first ones probably to come
back in person
i am a public member i'm not an
electrician so i'm
we
have it is very difficult i'm sure
for the director because there are
different rules
for each committee
we
regarding
criminal background checks are
discussing it now
but we haven't implemented anything
we do have a rule that says we cannot
look back more than 10 years of a
criminal history
so they have to fill out their
application whether they've ever been
convicted of a felony and if they have
you know we can't discuss it if it's
been more than 10 years
we have utilized that on a few occasions
where people
were involved with
trying to bring young women across
high school girls across
state lines for
nefarious reasons and we denied that
based on that so it concerns me when we
have a situation where
someone is saying well we're not going
to look at character i'm sorry i can't
agree with that 100 percent now in my
two or three years on the board we've
had that one case
that we felt that was appropriate and
again we are trying to look into
background checks because the
electrician's board currently does not
utilize those while others do
the comment was made that what is going
on right now is not working jesus i
don't know if i take offense to that or
not it may not be working for certain
committees
but it is working for others
why do we do this why do we have these
boards
other states it's dealt with by the
government
new hampshire you know the old new
hampshire way we have members of our own
peers in our own committees
people in our industry can better
understand what's going on whether we
know someone
yeah just caught doing something they
probably shouldn't have been doing or
whether they're a bad egg and they're
doing something wrong in the industry
we have that ability as individuals i'm
concerned
by this bill only of the fact of if you
have a committee that is not showing up
well that's a problem that chairman and
that thing that needs to be dealt with
but if if the committee if the
administration gets so backed up that
these things are automatic in 60 days
and we're not looking and we're not
looking at some of these
character type things
i just see that pendulum swinging toward
more of a government control
and less of what we like to have it now
or members of our peers
without question there are things that
go on
with 50 or 70 some boards i don't
remember the number
that are very inconsistent now this
isn't the place to do it
to rewrite everything
everyone's doing the best they can
but
i just
my only concern as a representative you
do this long enough
we've all
approved and voted for bills that the
following year we have to come back and
say oh we got to change that because we
didn't think about that
when we were the
the negative consequences so i just want
to make sure in the back of my mind is
this
taking too much away from the boards and
doing their responsibilities
and basically saying okay hey it happens
at a certain time and that's the way it
goes now
this is electrician's board maybe we're
a little more well organized maybe we're
a little more aggressive and
agitated and what have you
um it does and i can't speak for all the
other ones that aren't meeting it is
very disturbing to hear
that some of these boards are not
meeting
considering how much time and effort we
i'm sitting here madam chairman again
as i stated i'm not sure
whether i agree or not yet because i
don't know what the consequences could
be thank you madam chair thank you for
your testimony will you take some
questions
yes okay russian pearson and then grota
thank you madam chair i'm certainly not
shocked that the electrician's board is
actually functioning
as it should considering the safety
aspects involved
but if looking at the specific piece of
legislation especially on line three
this is more of a triggering
act in the sense that you know in the
event a board does not meet so you know
this really puts the ball into the
board's court in the sense that
do your job
and no problem and
short of that
i mean is that does that not satisfy
your concerns in in the sense of the
oplc taking over basically a board's
function
to be brutally honest with your
representative you you folks deal with
this
a lot and you understand the ins and
outs more than i as i understand more
the ins and outs of labor than possibly
if you were coming to my committee
so
as i said i'm not opposed or against i
just want to make sure that all avenues
are looked at to make sure this is not
more of a movement away from this
quote that was just stated that this is
that
it's not too much of a movement
away from what the board's
responsibilities are and toward the
government
but yes it is
more pleasing to have that sentence in
there than not
thank you representative
thank you madam chair
would you agree that the
boy i'd have to think about that
ultimately
some order to all of the occupations
that we have and i would say underlying
many of those have to do with safety i
agree with that
follow-up
and therefore
if the boards have the authority
and they do not meet
unlike your board and i believe that the
director did say that trade boards
have a better reputation than other
boards on meeting how would you
i'm sorry representative uh
we could sit down and have an hour-long
discussion about some of my ideas of the
oplc and what should be done but i'm not
going to disagree with what again
i'm going to keep saying the same thing
guys
i'm not in agreement or disagreement of
this i just want to make sure it's not
an overreach
thank you
other questions
remember scitec
well it could be that the electrician's
board is a little more important than
the board of hammock safety something
like that but my question is this
do you does the electrician's board deny
a license if somebody had a felony
conviction
we have
why
ah the example i just told you
that kind of felony okay
we get people coming in front of us that
have been convicted of mostly
related crimes where they were involved
with a break-in because of that they
present to us
how they were incarcerated rehabilitated
they get usually something for a parole
officer
they talk about the programs they've
been involved with and how they're back
on the straight and narrow and you know
we have to evaluate those things
okay
thank you
representative
infant time would you be
pleased to know that this bill actually
changes the current law which says that
if you apply for any license
if the board does not meet within 60
days you will get such a license
so that you could for example get a
doctor's license from the board of
medicine regardless of your
qualifications
and we're trying to stop that
is that does that reassure
your a few of your concerns
there are other questions
okay thank you very much for your
testimony we'll have to consider this
thank you it's always uh
good to be in front of edna okay
is there any other person who wishes to
all right seeing none i'll close the
public hearing and we have five minutes
no
we're going to open the public hearing
for house bill 1018 right relative to
the board of medical imaging and
radiation therapy
representative goalie you recognize
introduce the bill
thank you madam chair
and members of the committee for the
record
representative jeff goalie representing
hillsborough
8 manchester's ward 1
and here today to introduce house bill
relative to the board of medical imaging
radio radiation therapy
this was a request of the
director direct courtney of oplc
so with that i will turn it over to her
to further dive into
what the bill entails
see no questions thank you for your
testimony
thank you madam chair members of the
committee again for the record lindsey
courtney executive director office of
professional lace insurance
certification
as the committee is aware we
are the state agency charged with
providing administrative support to
approximately 50 boards that have
independent regulatory authority
and we also
directly regulate for professions with
advice of advisory councils
we've we've had a lot of discussion i
think earlier about uh some issues at
oplc issues with the board's issues with
the agency and structure
from my perspective
for an occupational licensing structure
to be successful
the state really has to leverage
expertise of professionals in those
occupations
there are some there are some states
that that don't do that at all and i
think that you lose
the ability to accurately protect the
public if you don't actually know how to
practice your profession
but you also need individuals who are
well experienced at administrative law
and procedure
and you need to marry the two together
so members of the regulated professions
are certainly experts in their fields
they're generally not experts in
administrative law and procedure
state officials may have vast experience
in administrative law but they don't
know anything about a particular
profession
so how do these individuals how should
they work together
in order to ensure that the needs are
met of the state i think it has to be a
harmonious relationship in order to
achieve the state's mission of
protecting the public
the structure this structure really
breaks down when a body is not able to
or is not consistently able to perform
its role in the relationship and as as
you've heard earlier today on other and
another bill
there are several plc boards that either
do not have a quorum or are struggling
to consistently maintain a quorum
this obviously significantly impacts
licensure and the state's ability to
protect the public
i truly think that most of these issues
are due the fact that our health care
boards are comprised largely of
individuals who are working in the
health care field which is experiencing
dire shortages
and it's not for lack of you know
wanting to to show up and attend and
participate
but those people are obviously
desperately needed on the front line and
not necessarily all the time in board
meetings
i believe that changing
those boards that are facing quorum
issues in particular
would permit board members to freely
provide their expertise
concerning potential regulatory changes
and licensure
and other matters even if they lack a
quorum
so for an example my
electrology advisory committee
the agency itself has rule making
authority
um for
a long time
the rules had been expired i think
dating back to when they were at dhhs
we had not we have not been able to
convene a physical quorum of the
committee but i was able to have
conversations with these committee
members and we were able to put together
a draft and file rules
that everybody was
comfortable with
and government continue on
so
when oplc was considering which boards
should potentially move to an advisory
model which is the model that many other
states use for small professions
this board came to mind as it as it
struggled to me once the boards were no
longer permitted
to have remote meetings in may
the board did not hold monthly meetings
in may and june the september and
november meetings were canceled due to
lack of a quorum
but they have they have been
making good efforts
to meet understanding that it's
important they did meet in july august
october
and i think this past month
the agency which is just wishes to
protect the public by ensuring qualified
applicants can be licensed in a timely
fashion and that the state has a
mechanism to effectively regulate this
profession we've talked about
contingency plans this is one type of
contingency plan to make sure that the
state has the ability
to regulate the profession
oplc has watched healthcare board
members struggle to take time out of
their busy lives to attend board
meetings and
i significantly appreciate their service
i've got people traveling down
from littleton
but we also understand that they're
they're often needed elsewhere and often
with lack of
notice
we are extremely concerned that if
meetings are not consistently held that
some individuals may be improperly
licensed or not licensed in a timely
manner and complaints will not be
addressed we we do have boards that have
complaints as i've noted that are not
being adjudicated
so i think moving this certain boards to
an advisory model would permit the state
to leverage the board members expertise
while ensuring that the state performs
the duties it's required to do in order
to adequately protect the public
and we certainly think that the mrt
board fits that bill
thank you for the opportunity to provide
comments i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you representative pearson you're
recognized
thank you madam chair i
in looking over this and this may this
is directed to you and to
um both representative golia mcguire to
think about here when we
when we change the definition of board
on page one line three
to make it an advisory board that that's
all well and good
but when you go through the rest of this
bill the word board is struck out
of
everything
so
we change the definition of board and
then we removed the word board from
from this particular area of regulation
so
i'm
on the surface i see that as a is
potentially a fundamental flaw here
in the sense that
you've created an advi you know you've
now changed it to an advisory board
but the advisory board now has no
function
as it's been struck out
and changed to executive director
everywhere
so i i
i would disagree um this is the
statutory framework for our other
advisory boards
in the sense that the agency itself
has regulatory authority
typically with consultation
and we would certainly support a change
that would require consultation
um with advisory boards but the advisory
boards that we currently have um
don't have independent regulatory
authority and that
so that there's typically a statute that
sets forth what the advisory board is
supposed to do
and you can see that in line
21 the advisory board shall advise the
executive director regarding the
implementation of this chapter
if we retained the board language in all
of these areas
like 24 for example
if it if we retained the board shall
adopt rules pursuant to rsa 541 relative
to yadda yadda we wouldn't exactly solve
the problem because we would still need
to convene a quorum of the board that
may not may or may not be meeting in
that particular area i can i can clearly
see your point there it's just in other
areas
it seems as though you have an advisory
board that has no authority to advise
anywhere because you've removed them
from
from everything
that's just i'm trying to get a sense of
and you're doing a good job explaining
it as to what what this
what this picture looks like now
yeah i think it could probably be better
described it's it's certainly described
in lines 20 and 21
shall advise the executive director
regarding the implementation of this
chapter there certainly could be
parameters around that you know shall
the executive director shall call a
meeting x number of times a year or
whatever
to make it clearer as to their function
because i certainly think that like i
said earlier we need to
essentially marry the two functions
together we need to carry out the
functions that that the state has
directed us to do
but we also need to leverage their
expertise
and that has to be an important part of
representative schuett
thank you madam chair um
and uh this is sort of addressed to
who i think will be the chair of the
we had agreed the four of us
representatives maguire goalie schmidt
and myself
to co-sponsor most of these advisory
board
possibilities
this one you see does not have my name
on it so i didn't see the language until
after the bill was
technically made public
i went through the bills that i
sponsored primary
and in various places where it required
decisions about education administrative
rules what have you
and change the language to say the
executive director
in consultation with the advisory board
which i think enables the board to still
be the one making the considerations
and i would propose that this bill be
amended
in the places where it does not
specifically
um
inhibit the representative duties
i i think we might be going down down a
rabbit hole of this might be better
discussion for our executive session i'm
stating this to then say to
the person testifying would that be
agreeable to you
yes absolutely
thank you that was my point
thank you representative sytek and then
representative marsh
i think now my question is redundant
because it
the representative show it's in
consultation with i was going to ask why
not just put or
yeah you can i
yeah i mean i think
the issue right is who decides where
we've had issues uh i'll give you a
prime example um body art um there needs
to be some sort of veto capacity
the the board had sought legislation to
allow other members of the profession of
the cosmetology profession not body
artists to perform microblading
so we so we pursued that bill um
and
but but when it came time for rulemaking
they received a lot of nasty grams from
colleagues who were concerned that i'm
bringing in additional individuals
would
compete be you know basically put them
out of business so the body art board
turned about face and said we don't want
to do this anymore
um and i was able to say to direct them
no we have this regulatory requirement
we need to move forward
if it was an ore i'm not sure we would
have actually been able to accomplish
that so there i think there always needs
representative marsh
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question i think my
questioning is following the same lines
as what uh representative schuett was
going at i'd like to look at page 3 line
28 as an example where it's discussing
the educational qualifications of
these people
and
i'm wondering if you truly believe the
executive director by herself or himself
could set the criterion standards
or with that very specific instance
where it's a clinical decision and the
input of the board is actually
exceedingly valuable if we should in
every one of those places change it to
executive director in consultation with
the board whereas leaving all the
administration functions strictly with
the executive director we would support
that
do any other members have any questions
for miss courtney
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you for your time
are there any other members from the
public that wish to testify on house
bill 10 18.
i'll get you a pink card when i'm done
so uh being on the on the uh
bill as has had been noted with regard
to representation and representative
goalie and representative mcguire as
well uh we have a series of these bills
we're hearing today but i'm sure that
the committee has been getting a deluge
with
emails with regard to one of the
subsequent bills
where
the public is very concerned about
stripping the the board members out of
any authority uh and
so i just want to say that
in the in the whole process of putting
these bills together
in consultation with oplc
uh the four
uh longer-serving members of the uh
this committee
have uh
uh
been willing to consider the idea of
restructuring uh the the nature of the
relationship between boards and
the executive director
but always the underlying idea was uh to
uh
to have the executive director and the
and the oplc
do the administrative end of things
where they have expertise
and the
retain their authority with regard to
the
niceties intricacies and
guts if you will of
the profession uh where they have the
expertise so
i kind of like as i like to say you know
the left leg does its job the right leg
does its job uh that's what we call
walking and you have to have at least
two legs to be able to walk
uh and if you are
crippled and have only one
functioning leg you may be able to hop
like heck but you can't walk
uh so what we want to do with regard to
uh to this
concept we're trying to develop here
is to have the agency function
uh
in a in a degree with regard to the
administrative end of things and the the
board members and the professionals to
retain their their authority their
influence their oversight and so forth
with regard to the the profession itself
um and and that's what we
that's what this previous colloquy
between representative schuett
represented mars marsh versus pearson
and the chair uh have been attempting to
do i just want to emphasize that that
that that's a discussion that several of
us uh that are on these bills have been
having uh so we are in full support of
the idea of streamlining things
improving the function
but not in any way of taking the
professionals out of
their area of expertise
but rather to uh to lighten the burden
on them with regard to administrative
things where they may not be all that
knowledgeable they may not have legal
background administrative background
they know their profession
um and that's where we should uh
emphasize their activity on the board
but in no way is is my intent as a
co-sponsor of this bill to be that the
the executive director will become the
be all and end-all and the advisory the
the board members the professionals uh
will be along for the ride but uh but
have effectively no say
uh so that's uh that's a no-go on my
part so uh i've been on the thing i
could not be asking questions from the
side that you're on uh so i've chosen to
uh come up and testify but uh so i i
hope making it clear we're going to be
seeing this especially
when we get to midwifery a little bit
later in
today's list
but i'll ask answer any questions people
may have
it sounds like this will probably go to
at least a tiny subcommittee
and would you think is do you think
would be a good idea to put in
that the board can
itself call for a meeting doesn't does a
bill say that
i think if we're is going to go to a
subcommittee we ought to have a dialogue
with regard to how we see this new
concept as being most
effective
because we certainly do not want to get
into a situation where the
uh
where the advisory board is effectively
powerless uh they're just uh
a gab fest
uh
or a
coffee clutch uh so i i think your
suggestion is
as viable as we as
some of the other ideas we've been
you're welcome
seeing no further questions thank you
are there any other
members of the public that will testify
for house bill 1018
seeing none we will close the public
hearing
i'd like to go into executive session if
if there are no
fine
and representative goalie you have a
motion
thank you madam chair i
will move that we
by representative o'brien
if you do you wish to speak to your
motion representative goalie uh briefly
i think uh we heard that
currently there is no way for
[Music]
the director or anyone to
stop handing out licenses if a board
shall not meet and make a determination
within a certain time frame on a number
of licensures
and this addresses that issue
and will give the director some
oversight
if this happens um so i think this is a
positive move and
i hope everyone will support it okay
representative o'brien you we should
speak to your second
chair we go thank you madam chair uh
representative cooley was quite eloquent
uh not much to say other than uh i do
believe the testimony director courtney
shows the need for this bill and thus
supporting it thank
you thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to speak representative
thank you um
i think we're
licensing way too many professions and i
think in a case where if the board can't
even be
people either aren't willing to be on
the board or they uh
can't even bother to meet we should drop
licensing for it rather than um than
doing this so i will be voting against
this thank
you anyone else representative schmidt
and then
i'll defer to represent pearson for the
moment
okay
um you know
the the function the function of
government you know as we talk about the
word function is is
it has to function i mean as cheesy as
it sounds and when we clearly have a
situation where government does not
function that does not serve
anyone it doesn't serve the people it
doesn't serve the professions it doesn't
serve the agency it doesn't serve the
consumer it doesn't serve anybody
so
you know we've those of us that have
been on this
committee for a while have seen time and
time again where we have examples of of
the inability to function
so
having
this piece of legislation come forward
to
provide an avenue to cr
intervene in some of the functionality
issues i think is a good thing
this is not a takeover
i call these trigger bills because you
know in the event of if an agency fails
if
some you know if the people the main
body doesn't do something
then action gets transferred it doesn't
strip the power away from a board
as long as the board does its job and i
think that not only is this triggering
bill not a takeover but maybe it's a
little bit of a kind of a kick in the
seat to some of these boards to say hey
you know the fact that you wanted to be
on a board but you're not going to show
up for the next two years isn't going to
fly anymore
so i do support this um
this broad effort here and then you know
we can get into the minutia of the 54
different boards as to as to whether or
not those need specific
either modifications or removals but as
a general overall broad
ability to keep
the state of new hampshire running in
regards to this i think this is uh this
thank you ma'am chair and thank you
representative pearson for your uh for
your take on the issue uh i i also am
sympathetic to the idea that if we have
a uh you know the
the
government being hamstrung by
a refusal of a board uh to function
uh
then we
that's not the public interest and we
certainly should be um
be trying to remedy that situation so as
i say i'm
fundamentally sympathetic to the idea uh
i guess i would have preferred if we
had had some kind of a a subcommittee
frankly where we could have kicked
around
the various different possibilities or
ramifications here because we are
basically uh you know enabling uh
the
the government to go forward
uh on virtually anything and and if
we're issuing a license or a permit uh
for some action uh we're this is a jump
off the cliff um to some degree
if we have not had an opportunity to
think through
some of the ramifications as i say of
what
might be done
representative schmidt
aren't you
you're confusing that with the bill we
passed last year where we said if the
boards don't act the oplc will issue a
license within 60 days this is a
restriction on the ability of the oplc
to issue the license well
that's why i
i think we i would have preferred
if i it's a
question of yay or nay i'm likely to say
yeah
but i i hope we'll have a thorough
discussion of because this is pretty
open-ended
and
i'm just a little bit uh reluctant to to
proceed without uh having had that
discussion and here in executive session
we're already making a
uh a statement of ought to pass without
uh without uh
exploring this a little bit further
while i agree enthusiastically with
representative lekkis about too many
boards being
pre in their in this quorum issue
i will be voting for this because it's a
step in the right direction because we
are growing rapidly think about this on
tuesday
director courtney told us there were 50
licensed boards now there's 58 today so
it's even in the past couple days it's
just exploded i mean it's just wow hi
breathtaking
that's a good point representative
goalie
thank you madam chair and i just want to
address the comments by representative
schmidt about jumping off the cliff
i think this puts the rails at the top
of the cliff and stopping the jumping
this allows the
executive director to
prevent someone from getting a license
if they're not qualified this allows
that to happen currently
we're jumping off the cliff by handing
out licenses if the time frame isn't met
we heard if you wanted to be an
audiologist
during covert was the time to go do it
because you didn't need any
credentialing just apply
and you given the license because
nobody's reviewing them and nobody's the
boards aren't meeting
this allows her to stop that from
happening this puts the rails up on the
top of the cliff and isn't jumping over
the cliff anymore that's what's
important about this thank you other
other comments representative allegro
i'm really
torn on this one and i kind of
want to reflect
or reiterate some of the concerns of
representative lekkis and infantine i'm
i'm not sure at this very second which
but like rep lekkis
i worry that we create bureaucracies
and then we grow them and then we bring
them under government control
and i'm not sure that that's an
improvement so i just wanted to express
that sentiment thank you
anyone else representative pearson i
would just like to
once again reiterate that this is a
triggering bill in the sense that
this does not
transfer authority
directly to
the administration of oplc it requires a
board
to fail to do its job before that occurs
where authority is is being moved it's
it's actually not being moved at all the
boards still retain everything here it's
just if they don't do their job
now we have a mechanism for government
any other questions comments
okay seeing none i'd like to say i agree
that it's
the rail at the top of the cliff because
the
as as the law stands right now
oplc is required to issue a license to
somebody that on the application form
clearly does not meet the requirements
and they still must give them
a
a license
i believe that's an unacceptable
situation
okay anyone else
representative scitec representative
schmidt
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good
thank you for that uh sentiment
representative lackas
thank you i understand why people
support this um and
i mean there is an issue where
if you give somebody a license without
checking at all
in effect you're putting the state's
imprimatur on them as being okay
when we haven't done anything and i
understand that concern
but
my issue with licensing and all the
professions we're licensing that i don't
think we should will result in my my
voting no although i understand it's
it's going to pass but thank you
representative
thank you madam chair
i would just point out to the newer
members of this committee that
we've put a lot of the restrictions on
licensing people particularly in the
medical professions in place
after what happened at exeter hospital
if you're not familiar there was a med
tech there who
i actually was an orderly i think
who
ended up
through miss actions which should have
been caught through criminal records
checks
ended up killing several patients at the
hospital and a lot of these protections
were put in place because of that but
with the situation we're in right now
those protections are not being looked
at necessarily
so i would hope that you would support
this
and give the board
i mean sorry the oplc the opportunity to
stop someone like that
at least temporarily from actually i
don't believe that that person would
have been disqualified because you'd
have to look at the criminal records
checks
and that's not something the oplc is
he did have the technical protection
madam chair he did have
some bad reports from previous
jobs maybe
yes i think the issue of whether we
should be licensing a profession or not
is something that we will be discussing
in great detail
in the future and probably forever
but in this case where we have regulated
professions that
can be granted licenses with
without meeting the minimum statutory
requirements is something that is i
think a failure of of the government
all right having had the last word the
motion is ought to pass by
representative goalie and the clerk can
call the role representative rhodes
yes
representative yakovich no
representative lekkis no
representative allegro no
representative bailey
no
i'm sorry
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
yes representative schmidt
yes
representative marsh
representative fellows yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien
the motion passes 11 to 5 it will not go
on consent
does anyone plan to write a minority
report representative lackas
okay
that is due at your very earliest
convenience
report all right
representative jacob of which you have a
motion
um yes i i'd like to move
house bill 1273
forward for an itl
this is the um
relative to the use of free and open
source
software
what was the bill number please 1273
goalie
yes so hey representative yakubovic yes
so our committee subcommittee met this
morning
we discussed the bill the i.t director
was here
the sponsor of the bill was here some
supporters we went through
the information
i got from the director
i can send it to the full committee it's
very interesting it's
what
what his job entails it's
thousands of computers it's um
11 000 and licensed end users for pcs
it's 2500 mobile phones it's 350 tablets
handheld tablets it's a bunch of cloud
services from amazon and
in the future google microsoft and
salesforce
and his department is running over a
hundred million dollars
every year
the budget for the department is 100
million dollars so i i think
the way yeah i described it was i don't
want to micromanage it
necessarily and tell him what to use
whether it's a dell computer or hp
computer he has to buy
so this bill
is brought forward is a very complex
bill it touches upon different many
different parts we discussed it also
that maybe it's a good idea to break it
up and send it to various
other committees because it talks about
criminal justice issues such as
uh the right
to well face the accuser and the
question the devices used in criminal
proceedings it talks about
restrictions and businesses it talks
about
the
council the advisory council
the sponsor wants to be brought forward
to discuss open source it talks about
copyright issues which i don't think the
state gets involved in at all even
um that's why we moved it to itl
and the sponsor
needs to work with the director and
other parties and
break it up and produce different bills
so thank you
thank you represent goalie do you wish
to speak to your second
very briefly noah and we have a another
hearing um i think
representative jacobovich
did a great synopsis of the subcommittee
and
the agreement was that if there were
seven different portions of this
some dealing with criminal justice
others that might have been better off
going to science in tech that he bring
this back and hopefully goes to the
appropriate committees thank you
all right thank you very much
other comments questions
representative marsh
uh yes uh thank you mr chairman uh i
intend to vote in favor of this motion
that that being said uh i
the reason why is because i agree this
bill is not ready for prime time at this
point in time it
many of us were first year reps it takes
a while to learn how to write a good
bill but we've all been there we've all
done that that being said i do believe
that there's substantial savings that we
could achieve in the state of new
hampshire by increasing our use of free
and open source software a very easy to
understand example would be using
libreoffice instead of microsoft word
which i think represents a substantial
uh expenditure by the icc that i believe
the department of
information technology has already made
that rather obvious step
i understand that but but that that
being said i think there is free soft
free and open source software and cost
savings to be had but this bill is not
ready for prime time thank you there is
another bill about open source software
that is recommended to pass with
amendment that might address some of
your issues yes i saw his hand thank you
representative laccas
thank you i agree with representative
marsh the only thing i'll say in
addition is that
it might make sense for it would make
more sense for the i.t council to take
this up and as was mentioned during the
hearing
it might make sense to you know put an
additional rep or maybe change the
membership in that but that's a separate
issue from this bill so thank you
any other comments questions
okay seeing none
the motion is itl on house bill 1273
made by rocco nyakovic second by
representative goalie the clerk can call
representative rhodes
yes clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative yakovich yes
representative alekas yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative santo nestaso
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy represented
schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair yes
16-0
the motion passed 16-0 is there any
objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put it on
consent
and thank you all for your efficiency
i think we will
end the executive session and thanks to
the subcommittee for their prompt and
oh if we have a minute
i might mention to the committee the
my subcommittee on massages
whatever that bill is
we'd like to meet after our session
hearings late afternoon after our
so i'm sorry was that originally for
tomorrow
no tomorrow is the call of the cola okay
so the massage is
subcommittees have to be noticed at
least 24 hours in advance
so
this is more than 24 hours in advance it
will be published and it
might make the calendar if you're lucky
public hearings have to be
right
yes
uh
is
um
reviews
foreign
yes
good
morning yes uh i'm
resuming action and opening the hearing
on house bill 1330
and i call the prime sponsor
representative
schmidt
yes sir you are not only the prime
sponsor you are the only sponsor so
thank you madam chair
so i'm pleased to be before
my favorite committee
that's as much as i'm going to grovel
at this point
but in any case i i do like the
committee and
after 15 16 years
so um
i'm pleased to bring uh house bill 1330
before the committee for its usual
thorough examination of the issues
and this is
one of these examples of
being
put into a new
mode where the executive director
is going to be
the attempt as i stated in the earlier
bill
previous bill is that
we want to attempt to shift
some of the workload
uh
more effectively from
the
the board
in terms of
not doing certain administrative things
that it perhaps does not have as much
expertise in
and by the same token maintaining
uh and and we may find that the language
needs the same kind of modification that
we've been talking about before where
things have to be done
um in consultation with the
the experts in the profession so that we
do not in any way
kind of neuter
the board
and the practitioners in the process of
governing them
by the same token
and conversations that we've had
with the um
with the executive director and with
some of the technicians over at oplc
what we're seeing is that very often
boards do not have
the kind of certainly the the kind of
legal and administrative
firepower or background or in some cases
knowledge
that the oplc has that's why they have
attorneys
and administrators and and we want to
get the the walking process to use my
previous analogy the walking process to
be
more one uh
where the the each each entity is doing
the area and the the activity
and the operation that it has expertise
and firepower if you will
in and and not be doing something in
which they are not so expert but um i'm
hoping that um and i'm seeing
uh the director here
uh i don't know that you're playing
testify can i
momentarily
you are planning to testify thank you
very much director courtney um so with
that uh since uh i i
performed my
most important task and that is is
introducing the bill uh i will defer to
uh director courtney for her expertise
on this particular issue thank you
oh good written testimony this time
call director
courtney
thank you madam chair members of the
committee lindsay courtney executive
director oplc
this is currently a board that lacks a
quorum statutorily
there are two members
and i believe one has indicated they
intend to resign sometime this summer
so at present uh they have not been able
sorry not two thousand thank you i was
that seemed a little ridiculous
and and this is a newer profession um
that this is uh the medical technicians
board
was fairly recently established
um so certainly our concerns are that
there's no statutory authority for us to
deny applications if the individual is
not qualified it looks like um that
house bill 1095 would resolve that
problem
but the board cannot conduct rulemaking
nor can the board take disciplinary
action because they do not have a quorum
the agency has received complaints but
there's no body that can act on such
complaints and as such we're greatly
concerned that the state is not meeting
its obligation to protect the public
which this legislature has decided
licensure is required in this field
certainly changing the board to an
advisory board is one way that would
permit the agency to act in the absence
of a quorum the agency could seek advice
of board members
to evaluate complaints register
individuals and deny registrations to
individuals who are not qualified
given the fact that essentially this
aspect of government is non-functional
oplc urges your support of this bill and
i'm happy to take any questions
okay thank you for before we get to the
questions i'd like to comment that this
will be going to representative
yakubovich's subcommittee
for a
combing of where we need to put in the
in consultation with language
which
after the previous discussions i'm sure
we need to
specify exactly where you need to have
so we don't need to worry about
that kind of detail representative marsh
thank you madam sharon and thank you for
taking my question
commission can you tell me how many
states at this point in time currently
licensed medical technologists and i
have a follow-up question my
understanding is we're the only state
representative
okay my my follow-up question is
can you tell me any circumstances where
a medical technologist would be
practicing independently not under the
supervision of their employer who may
have credentials
no
medical technicians are
[Music]
it's my understanding they're required
to act under supervision of a
practitioner
uh and one last follow-up question
follow-up uh
given those two answers would you be
supportive of uh bill if we amend this
to just simply repeal this licensure
um i
i
i would be willing to explore that um
i'm i'm familiar with the concerns
obviously surrounding hepatitis c i
represented actually half of the
plaintiffs in their lawsuits against
exeter hospitals so i'm intimately aware
of i think the knee-jerk reaction
after that
crisis or that issue but i you know i do
think that the data demonstrates that if
we are the only state that actually
licenses these individuals the state may
need to take it and take a further look
as to whether or not that's actually
required i i thank you and as a hospital
trustee was also interested in the
knee-jerk reaction to exeter hospital
who believes that the hospitals are
taking adequate precautions to protect
the public i would agree that this is
not a necessary function of your
currently overworked department so thank
you
thank you representative marsh i wish
you'd been on this committee a couple of
years ago when we faced the pleas to
register
all right are there any other questions
represent pearson
yeah just reading through this
similar to the prior one
the fifa renewal is struck out
of this
and i don't see
a because we've done this before with
with fixed numbers right we've let that
left that to the discretion of oplc to
make sure that we have fair and adequate
um renewal fees across the
50 to
58 boards depending on what uh
what time of day it is so
with this being struck out i i don't see
a mechanism in place
to have it
mirror what we've done in other places
is that
is that covered by another piece of
statute carte blanche and that's why
that's not in here or do we need to fix
that
yes it's covered by rsa 310 a
colon one dash
which grants
the authority to the executive director
to promulgate rules regarding fees
awesome thank you
other questions comments
well
congratulations thank you very much
thank you for your time
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
before we close madam chair i was
wondering if we could if we could do
something a little out of the ordinary
here it seems
yes it seems that there seems to be a
an opinion here as to whether or not
this board should even exist
so perhaps we should have some sort of
discussion in reference to that because
sending this to representative
yakubovich's subcommittee to to tweak it
may be unnecessary if if this is
something we need we want to dissolve in
its entirety i
i agree with you wholeheartedly and i
believe that subcommittee would be the
best place to discuss that
and
it would certainly be a germain
amendment if if they should decide to do
so
any other comments questions no seeing
none well as as long as you're asking
for a comment uh i i i think it's
important for the newer members to
understand uh that
point of order madam chairman uh i'm not
a point of order
representative schmidt is
in his teaching mode at the moment well
i i believe that if you recess the
public hearing then you could call an
executive session and comments from the
our committee would be in order but
you're correct i was out of order to
call for comments
are there is there anyone else who
wishes to testify
seeing none thank you
i'll close the public hearing
representative yakubovich i trust you
will schedule a
subcommittee meeting at your earliest
convenience
okay and we are off until one o'clock
you
it
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen it
being one o'clock we are going to open
the public hearing for house bill
1061 relative to midwifery council house
recognizes representative carol mcguire
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire representing
merrimack district 29 which is the towns
of allenstown epsom and pittsfield
house bill 1061
is a request
of the office of op plc
and
i wanted to say considering how much
attention it seems to have gone
that is that it is not an attempt to
remove
self-regulation from the
midwifery profession
it is an intent to consolidate the
administrative functions
away from the board and have them
concentrate on the professional aspects
such as
evaluation of applicants
consideration
of
continuing education
and any disciplinary actions that might
be required
and i know the board the bill does not
properly
address that in terms of
where the executive director can act
more or less
on our own first you know establishing
procedures and so collecting fees and
things like that
and where the board needs to get
involved for technical and professional
issues and therefore i expect it will be
going to subcommittee to deal with that
and
if that is the
if if the language is confusing or it is
doesn't ex
express
that intention
um i hope i hope it will not be taken
badly if we correct it
and i'll answer any questions i can
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question
i would specifically like to ask you
about section two of the bill
and as a matter of background while i'm
a licensed physician we had our last two
children at home with the midwife it was
a very positive experience but from that
experience i became aware of some of the
tensions between the medical profession
and the midwives
and my question relates to the advisory
council established where you're
establishing a council with
that will consist two-thirds
of
physicians or aprns whereas the existing
council is one-third of uh physicians
and i would like to actually i believe
the existing council is two physicians
one guy
one obstetrician and one pediatrician
right two out of six members is
one-third of the membership whereas here
it's two out of three which makes it
two-thirds of the membership so it seems
to me that
i'd like to know your rationale behind
making two-thirds of the advisory
council people who are not midwives
that was not
as i said this bill was a request of the
office of oplc and you'll have to ask
them for that i didn't make that
are there any further questions from the
members
seeing none
mr larue if you could accept my apology
i did not see the representative
representative
schmidt as one of the co-sponsors i
wanted to speak uh beforehand uh because
uh i've had some considerable
conversations
with uh with uh some of the public but
also with one of the members of the
current board
ms stevens uh several months ago uh
because
uh well i'll let let me just say
uh first of all
for the record representative peter
schmidt the representative stafford
19 which is dover awards one and two for
the last 19 years and uh
15 years on this committee so uh i want
to
assure the public that this this bill
is not intended
to
downgrade or
oppress
midwives or the
midwifery profession in any way
unfortunately has a couple of
significant deficiencies that need to be
addressed
i am fully in support of midwifery and
have been for many years although i've
never had to avail myself of a midwife's
experience my daughter was born 56 years
but in any case
the idea of the whole thing and
the committee has heard this before on
some of the bills we heard previously
that the the intention is to
facilitate
the professions
that we are
modifying in this fashion
we did not pick on midwives or pick on
any other profession but rather selected
a couple of small boards uh where we
could start off with the idea of trying
to enhance
administration
for the benefit of professions where the
board members may not have
indeed any board might might have the
same problem with
members who are not particularly skilled
at administration
or in the law or whatever but they are
expert in their own profession that
certainly is the case with midwives
and so what we want to do is
allow the
these members one of the other bills is
court reporters for example is also a
small board a small number of
practitioners uh
enhance their ability to
effectively
engage in their own profession but also
to give the oplc
the benefit of their experience in their
profession
without burdening them with
administrative or personnel
aspects at which they may not be
particularly expert or in the law
and so
my understanding is this bill is going
to to a subcommittee where we will be
or we will be addressing the
deficiencies
that are clearly
manifest uh
an immediate uh inspection of the of the
text where it
frequently just strikes out the board
and substitutes the executive director
it's clear and it was always our
intention and that the boards
that the executive director would only
be administering the board in
consultation with the practitioners who
have the technical skill knowledge and
experience
so um
one of the things we certainly have
established in this process is there's a
lot of public support
for midwives
and i i i rarely get such an inundation
of uh emails in support of a profession
even if very often was the same language
so
people don't have to write it in their
own language they were very manifest in
their intentions so if there are any
questions i'd be happy to
answer them otherwise i i look forward
to hearing the testimony from the
assembly representative scitec
representative schmidt is the public
invited to subcommittee
meetings
so the public is not only invited but
they are entitled uh to attend
subcommittee meetings our meetings are
all public
and the public is welcomed and invited
to attend because
that we benefit from what they can tell
us from their own experience
i hope that i hope we'll have a lot of
them present
because it's lovely to see all of them
these young young children
newborn babies and many kids are there
any other members that have a question
for the representative
see none thank you representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair
i'll be very brief
as a co-sponsor of the bill i became
aware
shortly after it was introduced that
there were a lot of deficiencies in it
among them
the membership and makeup of the board
i have had an amendment drafted
which restores the
five of the members of the board it
deletes the public member
and re-adds the qualifications of the
two physicians
that are currently in statute
i would also say that we probably will
be interested in
amending the bill to add that phrase in
consultation with
however i understand there's a large
push most of the folks present here
probably would like to see the bill
killed
if that happens
if that's the opinion of the committee
fine otherwise i have this amendment
ready to
present
no questions thank you for your
i think it's on yeah
thank you madam chair uh i'm
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown
um
24 hours ago i didn't know this bill was
coming to committee so i do not have
any uh much technical guidance to to
share with you
but uh i did get a lot of calls last
night and i learned
how to pronounce midwifery so
so that was a big deal for me uh
i i would say
some of the public testimony you hear i
think will be cautioned by just wanting
to be polite and a little intimidated by
the hearing process
and so you may not pick up on what i
picked up on and that is that there's a
palpable fear that this is uh an end
round a trick to start to figure out how
to kill the practice of midwives in new
hampshire and i've talked to um
the prime sponsor um representative
mcguire i don't believe that's her
intent at all but i did want to let you
all know that
there is that sort of fear uh
in this community uh one thing i i heard
that uh y'all are in a good position to
evaluate
is that in the membership um
they they thought
the participation of
practicing midwives is underrepresented
and apparently there's at least two
types of midwives there are hospital
midwives and there are in-home midwives
and apparently
the point of view of each is
sufficiently separated that the request
was made to me to ask the committee to
consider
having one of each
so that's really uh that's really my
testimony i i have a lot of faith in
this committee
tremendous technical work work that i i
could never do so i appreciate that you
guys are laboring this
thank you representative edwards i also
like to take this time to apologize for
mispronouncing midwifery at the very
beginning of this hearing
quickly realized my mistake are there
any questions for the representative
seeing none thank you representative
edwards
mr lemieux
can you hear me okay
um
oh perfect
perfect usually i speak without a
microphone um david larue um i currently
have a child on the way with a midwife
and i wouldn't want it any other way
you're darn right there's a lot of fear
i don't have the technical aspects to
speak about the midwife profession i'm
not registered i'm not a midwife
but i trust them
live free or die
i have to constantly say this phrase
when i speak to councils and committees
and people on the street
and
it seems that we've forgotten really
what that means again
how can we live free in new hampshire
how can we live free if we're not able
to be born free
okay you can't live a way that you can't
start and we already have a lot of
problems with our society and with our
system where our children who we entrust
these midwives to bring into the world
are born into a highly regulated
and not free society
and the question that was asked right
away why is the count the this new
council being made up not primarily of
midwives
that that is a great point and that's
and
from the sponsor of the bill it sounds
like this was
not the midwife organization in the
profession coming and saying hey we need
some help this was an outside
organization said hey those little guys
need some help because they're screw-ups
and we can really help them because they
don't know what they're doing and so now
we have this
and it used to be
used to be kind of a badge of honor you
know i'm hearing my coveralls and my
rubber boots and i'm from the country
and
you know the old-timers up north we
always used to hear oh yeah that guy he
was born in that house yeah grandpa he
lived and died in that house he they
died in the house that grandpa built we
used to have traditions we used to have
history we used to have legacy and in
new england we used to really have some
we're talking about legacy here and what
legacy does the midwife
the midwife leave what is their part um
we don't arrive at a stranglehold of
tyranny via a decisive action we don't
arrive at an industry being a shell of
themselves and a profession being
hollowed out and losing all that makes
them special we don't arrive at that
overnight through one bill
it's the death of a thousand paper cuts
and people are right to be um in fear of
bills especially poorly constructed ones
with good intentions
we hear every single bill no matter what
it is well it was made with good
intentions well i can tell you which
road to wear is paved with good
intentions
hospitals and the birthing industry is
big money
and i don't have to identify the
elephant in the room to say that we have
some serious issues in our medical field
and with people worrying about hospital
care right now worrying about what
they're going to receive what their
babies are going to receive
um it's the hospitals are our faceless
industry for the most part midwives are
an intimate experience
you don't get the relationship with the
hospital i don't care how many times you
see your doctor you do not develop the
trust and um
the you do not get to test the knowledge
of the physician and the team that's
going to be helping bring your child
into the world through the hospital
i definitely think this needs
more work
i would vote against it i would say it
needs to go back to the drawing board or
be scrapped
um and you guys need to let alone what
thank you mr larue mr larue
would would you be willing to take a
question from a member of the
committee
representative scitec
there apostrophe after the nose you
don't use it okay nope you got rid of
that
you know you're french a little bit
though
the house recognizes
thank you madam chairperson uh my name
is jaren blessing i'm
a resident of concord i strongly oppose
this bill um
i'm also an attorney
and
i certainly would never impute um bad
intentions towards
the people who drafted this bill
but reading it i read it yesterday for
the first time and it was clear it was
either
no no thought went into it whatsoever
because i was extremely alarmed when i
read it um
it read as a clear desire to
take over the practice of midwifery take
the decision making out of their hands
um
as an attorney we have professional
boards that govern our
licensure
in our conduct and if you were to tell
me that you wanted to put a midwife in
charge of that i would say you're crazy
um
i think this similar thing applies i
don't see any good reason
to give the executive director and
attorney
decision-making control over every
aspect of
the midwifery board thank you
see no questions thank you for your
testimony
the house calls
buford
it's all right you're not the first
person to mispronounce that and you
hello my name is nikki
i am a student midwife currently
completing the pep process to become a
cpm in the state of new hampshire and i
am also a doula running sacred sunshine
birth in keene new hampshire
as this bill stands without any
amendments
it threatens the autonomy of midwives in
new hampshire
truthfully home birth and midwifery
in new hampshire is already too
regulated
home birth needs to become more free
midwifery being under attack is nothing
new honestly
for the past hundred years or so
the over medicalization of the natural
process of birth
has pushed midwives out of the birth
process
so you can understand why we are
fiercely against this bill as it stands
without amendments
i fear that this bill as many all many
others have also stated that they also
fear
that this bill will take autonomy away
our neighboring new england states of
massachusetts and connecticut no offense
put us to shame
as far as birth freedom
women's rights regarding birth goes
i would like to see amendments to this
bill removing some of the state's
restrictions and regulations that we
already have on home birth i'm not sure
if that's possible as far as this bill
is concerned
but to start we absolutely need to
remove
restrictions like bmi
not allowing vaginal births after
cesarean after two cesareans
in other states these are allowed in the
home birth setting but for some reason
in new hampshire they are not
for example
vaginal birth after two
cesareans an elective c-section before
spontaneous onset of labor increases
risk of maternal mortality two to four
times compared to vaginal birth without
induction
meaning that actually it is more
dangerous
to give birth in the hospital with an
elective c-section than it is to give
birth at home with an at-home midwife
in cases of v back mothers
six per a thousand
um
maternal mortalities were with
home births in a hundred per one hundred
thousand were in the hospital with
repeat cesareans so
those numbers are also coming from the
mana the cdc and the nih in the c the
ncbi
breach delivery in twins can also be
safely delivered at home this is allowed
in many other states including
massachusetts but for some reason it is
midwives know how to assist women in
birthing their babies in a kind gentle
loving and safe way
midwives deserve the autonomy to make
the important decisions regarding
midwifery
again like some other people have
already stated it doesn't make sense to
put people that are not midwives in
charge of the midwifery boards we don't
tell obstetricians how to do their job
so why are they telling us how to do our
job
hospitals obs nurses and even yes most
certified nurse midwives don't speak the
language of home birth or natural
childbirth
it's ridiculous to have non-midwives
outnumber midwives on a midwifery
council
so again i urge you to amend this bill
or completely throw it out
to give midwives the autonomy they
deserve and to also remove
discriminatory regulations from home
birth
thank you for your time i will now
answer any questions that you might have
cena the house thank you for your
testimony thank you very much
hi there my name is natanya champney i'm
a midwife in new hampshire up in
littleton area i service the whole north
country i'm coming to you today on
behalf of the new hampshire midwives
association with an official document
from them which was sent to all of them
could you just spell your name for us we
didn't get any of that netanyah
n-a-t-a-n-y-a
also for you and for the other folks
testifying these microphones require
that you get rather close to them
so that folks
in the youtube world can can also hear
you gotcha
thank you so i will say it again that i
am a midwife in new hampshire in
northern new hampshire
run out of littleton i service the whole
north country all the way up to
colebrook and pittsburgh
and i am coming to you today on behalf
of the new hampshire midwives
association this is an official document
from our president
and i'm just going to read that
the board of directors of the new
hampshire midwives association on behalf
of our members strongly opposes the
as currently drafted by the executive
departments and administrators
we have concerns that administering the
powers and duties to a sole entity the
executive
director we will be removing will be
removing autonomy
and the ability to remain a
self-regulating body as we have for
over 30 years
licensed midwifery has a long-standing
ability to self-regulate
maintain responsibilities and address
disciplinary action
placing this responsibility on a sole
entity as the executive director stands
threatens the ability for licensed
midwifery to continue on as an
autonomous
knowledge-based regulatory system
as it is impossible for an executive
director to have a thorough
understanding of the practice and
profession without having experience in
such
as it stands the midwifery board is made
of physicians pediatricians and peers
experienced and well-versed in certified
midwifery
ensuring that rulemaking regulations
formalities and disciplinary actions are
appropriate and adequate to the
profession the to the midwifery
profession
additionally the amendment proposes
removing the public member of the
council we feel that removing
the midwifery consumer from the council
silences the voices of the general
public
and as we know the voices are many
the midwifery profession has always put
consumers public and community interests
at the foremost of their works
purpose
to remove this position not only has a
significant impact on the community we
aim to serve but also lessens the
integrity and respect of the profession
and the regulating body as a whole as
the new hampshire midwives association
we are asking that this bill be repealed
completely and that we continue to
remain a self-regulating profession
under the guidance and regulation of the
current midwifery board
the uh public person here will be
willing to take your question of course
thank you may i ask a question madam
chair
uh thank you uh i i suspect that i know
the answer to this question but i would
like it to be
entered into the record uh we received a
communication from oplc concerned about
the sherman antitrust act and possible
anti-competitive conduct by
due to the fact that there are only 27
active certified midwives in new
hampshire
it is my understanding that
anti-competitive behavior tends to raise
prices could you explain to us the
approximate difference in cost to a
family of having a home birth with a
midwife versus having a hospital birth
well
from my standpoint i take a sliding
scale fee i do not take insurance and i
am 3 800 for 11 months worth of care
um
and then a hospital i
believe
that the hospital for a normal birth
with no medication or anything is over
nine thousand dollars these days
uh thank you i think that answers my
representative judy yes thank you madam
chair
uh just a simple question
how many midwives you have here in new
hampshire
how many midwives in new hampshire yes i
believe
27 27.
i mean whole new hampshire 27
and uh how many school do you have here
in new hampshire there are no schools in
new hampshire for midwifery how do you
learn how do you learn to become a
midwife so you go to a accredited school
well there's two different paths that
you can take but one path is to go to an
accredited school
there was one in bridgton maine for a
long time they have gone out of business
but there's other schools in the country
that midwives go to and then they
our students go to and then they come to
new hampshire to do their preceptorship
with another midwife
and follow under their direction until
they have done the amount of births that
they need to in order to become a
midwife
follow up yes uh you
meet
midwife yeah we never have any problem
to deliver a baby
can you say that again i'm sorry
i speak too fast uh if we never have a
problem to deliver a baby
because you know at the hospital
there are some
babies that come
different way
upside down or
yeah so the practice of midwifery allows
us as midwives to follow women um
intimately during their prenatal time in
order to make sure and
to look at their history
make sure they are low risk clients that
are doing home birth and we we have very
clear ruling on all of this of how to
determine who is
acceptable for home birth
and not but
may i just remind you that home birth is
normal and it's been normal for a really
really really long time oh okay all
representatives
i'm from the city i'm a little uneasy
about midwifery and i don't appreciate
the education i want to try to open
open the mind as representative schmidt
might say uh my question is this um
it's allied with uh representative judy
what happens if something goes wrong
what do you do about it rh
incompatibility
uh so we have laws that that we have to
follow as midwives in order to
make sure that our clients are staying
low risk at all times and if they're not
then that is the wonder and blessing of
having a hospital to have them go to
if those things happen
but the rarity of those things is small
in comparison to
thank you i guess yeah
representative grota
you
thank you
um i don't have a question about your
profession or its standing or
my concern is the board yeah
so
when you have an application for a
licensee
does the board approve that
application
as far as i know yes it goes to the
council right now the midwifery council
is who regulates who becomes
a midwife in the state and it's done on
a number of different criteria that the
midwife has to
adhere to and that's how we get our
re-licensure every year as well i'm not
speaking on behalf of the council i am
speaking on behalf of the midwifery
association today
okay so
so
do you understand that the concerns that
we have have to do with the board rather
than
your profession you
home births
babies
um
the board has certain functions that it
has to do
and if it does not meet those
requirements
then
things that could affect you
as a group
could happen do you understand that i
understand that i do not think that is
accurate i as a midwife in the state i
have put in my application for renewal
time and time again i have personally
been late before and i have gotten a
phone call and follow-up and i have
never had any problems in in them doing
their job it was more me trying to
finish my part of the job um as the sole
midwife for my own professional
certification i have never had a problem
with the
midwifery council
i've never had a problem with them when
we've had to
administer um
uh
so if there is a
infant more morbidity or mortality or
maternal morbidity or mentality in our
um
while i'm a midwife you have to write
out a a sheet that says you know what
happened and
we always get phone calls from the
council right away it's i've never had a
problem whatsoever
last question so how does the new
hampshire
midwifery association
interact with the
midwifery board council
so
we have a representative from the
council that comes to the board to tell
us any
news that might be happening which is
how we found out about this
but the midwifery association is
is built so that we as midwives can come
together and look at how we function as
midwives and get information from each
other get help from each other
and
really it's best for our communication
and our furthering
thank you okay
representative o'brien thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
in listening to your testimony you said
that uh currently there's a member of
the public that is on the board
and i perused the bill and you know did
the homework and read it but
although i don't see it but how would
this bill change that public input
so as far as i'm con well as far as i
know so i'm not speaking on behalf of
the council today i'm speaking on just
behalf of the midwifery association but
as far as we were told
you
the
new advisory board that this bill is
asking
to be made up is only of two doctors and
a midwife
and our current council has three
midwives a doctor
an ob a pediatrician so two doctors and
a member of the public that is our norm
thank you for that clarification
appreciate it thank you madam chief
representative lekkis
just to comment on that representative
the bill replaces the current makeup of
the council so the existing makeup you'd
have to go look at the existing rsa
thank you for your testimony mr champney
thank you representative rhodes
um
i testify before you in opposition to
house bill 1061.
my name is dr heidi reinhardt i'm a
medical doctor licensed in the state of
new hampshire
i'm a board certified obstetrician
gynecologist in practice at the cheshire
medical center in at dartmouth-hitchcock
in keene
i
was appointed by governor sununu in 2018
to serve on the midwifery council
and previous to that i served for five
years on the analogous
licensed midwives advisory board in the
state of new mexico
i chose home midwifery care for the
births of each of my three children
i strongly oppose house bill 1061
the enabling legislation for the
certification of midwives in new
hampshire
chapter 326d states
and this is i quote
the intent of the general court to
preserve the right of women to deliver
at home
to remove obstacles to safe out of
hospital deliveries and to assure
quality a care
the bill established the midwifery
council with powers and duties to
certify midwives to investigate
complaints and undertake disciplinary
action
in addition the midwifery council is
charged with rulemaking for midwives
qualifications
scope of practice and policies for
professional direction and supervision
and as been
spoken about several times already the
composition of the midwifery council is
three certified midwives an obstetrician
myself a pediatrician and a community
member
lindsay courtney the executive director
of oplc met with the midwifery council
to explain that her goal in putting
forth house bills 1061 was to protect
against allegations of anti-competitive
decisions by the midwifery council which
we agree is a laudable goal if i
misrepresent what she explained to us
i'm sure she will correct you correct me
um it is in the interest of the oplc and
the state's interest that the midwifery
council not run afoul of the ftc's
commission or the ftc act by acting
anti-competitively
so here are the problems that i see with
first the executive director of oplc
would be given all power and authority
over the profession and practice of
midwifery in new hampshire
so it's absolutely appropriate that the
oplc be headed by someone expert in the
legal and administrative aspects
of licensure and certification
absolutely appropriate
and it's also appropriate for the oplc
to monitor and guide the various boards
and councils to remain within legal
guardrails that's not my area of
expertise and they will tell you
i can get into trouble in terms of the
legal part i need that advice and
counsel to stay in legal guardrails
but it is not realistic that an
executive director of oplc would have
the expertise
in the qualifications to practice
midwifery the scope of midwifery
practice and evaluating the competence
or deviations from midwifery standards
and yet house bill 1061 as it's as it's
submitted to to to you all
places all authority in the hands of the
executive director of the oplc
the midwifery advisory council as
outlined in the proposed legislation
would be unable to fulfill the mandates
of the enabling legislation
one might argue that house bill 1061
ensures appropriate input by the
executive director by retaining
an advisory council
but it would be composed of just one
midwife and two other members physicians
or aprns with experience in obstetrics
an advisory council is problematic for
three reasons
midwifery also involves care of the
newborn the perinatal period there was
no provision in the bill
for input from a pediatric health care
provider
two the history of medicine and
midwifery in united states has been
less than smooth
uh allopathic medicine my profession has
traditionally been his hostile to
midwifery and that's been
the truth for about 140 years
and few obstetricians have any knowledge
or direct experience with community
midwives
the state and oplc would be open to new
charges of anti-competitive behavior if
a physician dominant advisory council
attempted to curtail the practice submit
with midwifery
three
house bill 1061 functionally obliterates
the professional autonomy of midwives in
new hampshire by having only one midwife
as the sole voice influencing the
there is draft legislation that was
brought to the midwifery council at our
last meeting oplc draft legislation
dated 1-22 the amendment
is not on the general court bill status
website so i won't be able to address it
specifically here
representative mcguire referenced it
but it again it remains problematic
because it imbues too much clinical
guidance and authority
in a
executive director
or whatever the
credentials are of the oplc director in
legislators i stand before you committed
to fulfilling the mandate of chapter
326d on midwifery to remove obstacles to
safe out of hospital deliveries and
assure quality of care quality care
i oppose house bill 1061 and urge you to
reject it
i would be happy to work with the oplc
and legislators to shape a more
acceptable bill
thank you
are there any questions for me
representative marsh
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
i have two questions my first question
is would you believe that i am very
happy that i'm not the only licensed
physician in this room that chose home
birth
my second question is more pertinent and
it regards your role on the council has
the council had any troubles obtaining a
quorum and doing its business
uh we've had an illness recently that
altered our quorum ability to meet
quorum but
no generally i've been on the council
like i said since 2018.
and the illness is resolved now as far
as i know
thank you
my apologies representative grota and
you could we have a copy of your
testimony please of my testimony yeah
sure thank you
and how would be best for me to get it
to you
just give just hand it to you
sure
representative lekis and if you happen
to have an electronic form if you could
just email it to the uh
edna uh email address so we'd all get it
thank you let me show you where that
link is
thank you dr reinhart thank you
hi i'm sherry stevens i live in meredith
new hampshire
and i am here on the i'm the council
chair of the new hampshire midwifery
chair
how about if i take one off is that
better
all right
there you go better
okay
again i'm sherry stevens i live in
meredith new hampshire and i'm here as a
i'm going to start with a question
i have a statement written by the
council that i think you all were given
would you like me to read that or would
you like me to just
speak
if we've already received that
so i'm going to assume that you have
i can't speak for every member in the
room but i do believe most of us have
read the emails that were sent over to
us thank you okay
so um
the basic gist is that the new hampshire
midwifery
council is an opposition of this bill
for
the reasons that have been stated
previous so i do
not want to
dwell on that
answers that we've come up with with the
question
is
are we as the new hampshire midwifery
council
at risk for being sued or doing
something
untoward with not being administrative
rule
um
professionals
so our
stand is that we would like to keep the
nehesh midwifery council
of three new hampshire midwives
with one obstetrician that is
familiar with the practice of midwifery
and one pediatrician that is familiar
with the practice of midwifery and the
um public member we believe that voice
is very important
we understand the concerns of the oplc
and our way of
addressing that is that
um in order to preserve i'm going to
read this statement in order to preserve
the professional autonomy of the
midwifery council and to achieve the
goal of functioning within the legal
barriers we would endorse amending the
language in this proposal legislation to
reflect that the midwifery council
continues to act autonomously with a
consultation of the executive director
of oplc
and that everything that we do
we would ask for the
consultation of the executive director
or her designee therefore we have the
oversight that we think that they're
seeking
i did want to
go back and address one of the
questions i think that were given to
ms champney that on rh negative so in
our
if you have an arch negative mother the
concern is that she would
have an rh positive baby and and have
antibodies built up in her blood and so
in our formulary we have the ability to
obtain rhogam and
administer rogam to the mother so an
irish negative mother would be offered
that at her 28 week prenatal visit as
well as
obtain cord blood and decide if the baby
or determine if the baby is
rh positive and offer the mother a rogue
game shot
does that answer so i just want to make
sure that we we have a formulary in our
law in rh
our rsa
326d
that gives us a formulary to address
some of the
concerns that were mentioned what
happens if there's something wrong we
are able to
administer
medications to
help stem a hemorrhage we are able to
administrate
rhogam for an rh negative mom if
necessary
we are also part of we one of the things
that was brought up is what is our
certification process and one of the
certification processes and the
recertification process is that we all
are certified in cpr and neonatal
resuscitation so there
representative grota
thank you first of all i want to
commend all of you for coming here
and i know it's a bit scary
but you have to understand that from our
point of view you are the vital part of
this process
the public
so um i just want to pre i just want you
to know how much we appreciate
your efforts and your strength to come
here
thank you
um
so in if you were to if we were let's
just
talk about this consultation with the
oplc director or designee
how do you envision that happening
so the
as dr reinhart said the intention of the
original
rsa 326d which
in
81 was created to establish the
profession of midwifery
and then in 99 we established the
midwifery council
and the idea is that the midwifery
council likes many other boards in the
state has regulatory
control and that we would
have
it's a process
as most of you know if we have a rule
making we speak to the rulemaking
authorities from the oplc we worked in
connection to them we've done it several
times over
our rules come up we work with them and
then we present it to gelcar and it goes
through if we have a law change it would
go through the process
when we have we so we research we
certify and
recertify
midwives constantly
and so
i as the chair of the
midwifery council have for many many
years receive those applications vetted
them
made sure that they meet all the
requirements that are stated in the law
and rules
and then we
would issue that midwife
certification
and when oplc
came on board and as we've worked with
them we've continually tried to work
with them and say
here's our process here's what we're
doing and they say okay here you have an
administrator and we're going to help
you with that process
they give us an administrator and they
help us run our meetings they you know
we have if we have an investigation they
now have the enforcement
part of oplc that we work with and we
have been absolutely 100 percent
willing to work with them tried
everything we can to work with them
we have consistently had different
people come in as our administrator so
like we just get working with one and
then a new one comes in and it's just
been a difficult process but we're 100
dedicated to that process we want it to
work we would love our meetings to run i
have attended the
justice department's
training on how to run a meeting how to
run an investigation since 2015 and we
are absolutely committed to doing our
job as
as
purposefully and as legitimate as
possible
so we have no problem working with the
oplc if that is what their
um
in fact i have that their whole their
law was established
to give administrative support to the
boards and so our
law says we have
our council to regulate the profession
of midwifery and the oplc
was created to give the boards that
administrative support
absolutely 100
agree with that we were happy to work
with them we're not trying to do
anything outside of that
but
the state of new hampshire has this
wonderful autonomous board of
midwiferies we're very lucky to have
that it is not true in all 50 states
and so we are the state that most states
look to and say this is what we want in
new hampshire being live free or die and
being the wonderful state we are has
created that and the legislative has
been very supportive of midwifery
profession
since the 80s so we're very grateful for
that
and we're not looking to change that at
all and so giving
all that
all this
autonomy to one
person at the
oplc makes no sense whatsoever
if they're concerned about what we're
doing then please come into our meetings
which they do
and anything we do we say hey is this
the right way to do it and if we're
doing something
incorrect and correct us please you know
we want to stay within the law thank you
representative marsh
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
ms stevens for taking my question it's a
great pleasure to see you again after
all these years i
appreciate a chance to catch up
just to be clear is it the position of
the midwifery council that we kill this
bill or do you believe we can amend it
in such a way to make it actually be
useful
i
it is the recommendation we kill this
bill
thank you
the
office of professional licensing and
certification there
created to support the boards
and so
us saying you know even a thing you know
we
anywhere in in our law that says the
council is
you know supposed to do this or that
adding with the consultation of the
executive director
seems redundant to me because it's
already their job to oversee us but we
are happy to put that language in if
that's going to give them
um
security that we're not you know then
we're following things correctly
thank you for your testimony
i'm not sure how to pronounce this
last name so
good afternoon
vice chair rhodes and members of the
house executive departments and
administrative committee my name is
evelyn asa i'm a resident of concord new
hampshire i'm here today to express my
opposition to house bill 1061.
i'm here in my capacity as a private
citizen and someone who benefited from
the expert midwifery practice in our
state in 2014 i gave birth to my
daughter sabine at home under the expert
care and guidance of two highly skilled
new hampshire certified midwives and
their then apprentice
but i'm also here today because until
last month i served as the consumer
member of the new hampshire midwifery
council a position i was honored to be
appointed to and hold for nearly seven
years
it's from these two
highly informed perspectives that i find
this proposed legislation unnecessary
and frankly disconcerting
for three decades the practice of
midwifery in new hampshire has been
successfully regulated and overseen by
the new hampshire midwifery council
during my near seven year tenure on the
council we went to great lengths to
uphold the serious responsibilities of
our position
at the center of the council's work was
and remains an unwavering commitment to
the well-being of those eligible
to seek a safe alternative to hospital
birth
in recent years the oplc has made a
concerted effort to better support the
work of the midwifery council
we leveraged every aspect of it
available to us as we carried out our
work that support was generally a
helpful addition to the expertise of our
members of our council though it often
brought delays to our processes and
procedures sometimes by several months
due to constant changeovers in staff
staff roles and an overall lack of
clarity within oplc about oplc staff
roles and processes
nevertheless the relationship between
the council and the oplc was on the
whole a complementary one that allowed
our expert council to ensure the highest
standards for the practice of midwifery
in new hampshire
and effectively oversee and regulate the
profession
hb 1061 was drafted and filed by oplc
with no advance notice
no input and no opportunity for
collaboration with the new hampshire
midwifery council
it is an ill-informed solution in search
of a problem
and one that has potential to
fundamentally undermine the safe
practice of midwifery in our state
this bill is crafted by oplc proposes
for midwifery in new hampshire to no
longer be directly regulated and
overseen by the council it also omits
the public members perspective which
we've discussed ad nauseam today
so what could go wrong in having the
complex history profession of midwifery
directly regulated and overseen by
furthermore as this proposed bill was
introduced without any communication
with or guidance from the council itself
it is also reasonable to question
whether this proposed advisory board
would have any meaningful influence over
the decision-making and oversight of the
executive director
so in the simplest terms there's no need
for this legislation the new hampshire
midwifery council should continue to
effectively lead in the direct oversight
and regulation of the practice of
midwifery in our state as the council
has done for 30 years
i urge you to vote in expedient to
legislate and of course i welcome your
questions
are you willing to take a question sure
um from your experience can can you tell
me how the oplc staff
interacts with your board
you know are they there at every meeting
and what services do they provide yes i
can say over those seven years um or
almost seven years that relationship has
changed
um largely in a favorable direction
so in the last several years we've had a
member of their staff present in every
one of our meetings
taking minutes informing our processes
providing us with sample language if we
have to issue letters to
midwives or otherwise take action
so it's been a very helpful relationship
as i noted there have been some
delays to our process there's you know
some lag time oftentimes in
implementation of things
but it has been a beneficial
relationship and frankly i don't see a
follow-up
and uh just one other thing about your
meetings
do you feel that
being able to hold virtual meetings
would be a help or not i think it's
extremely helpful particularly as
members of the council live all over the
state and have considerable drive time
so yes
thank you for your testimony
hi
good afternoon i'm coming today with
nothing written i'm coming with 40 years
of experience
as a traditional doula excuse me if you
could just state your name for the
record julie
and i'm coming today as a mama of nine
babies
most home born
most of them 10 pounds
in my traditional doula work now i said
all all mamas need is a mama in the room
with them as they're laboring
to know that here this mom has had many
ten pound babies at home
works magic
so i'm coming with a little bit of i
said three minutes on my talk time
so somebody just kind of tell me but i'm
coming today with a little bit of a
viewpoint from a home birth mama and
from the home front
like the young man who spoke about
expecting his baby soon
along with my nine babies we now have 29
grandbabies
and midwives have been catching them and
these midwives in new hampshire are
magic
along with skilled
knowledgeable
experienced
amazing
not only do they support their mamas
they support extended families
in
a lot of different different situations
and always towards a healthier more
independent
family life
i'm now
looking at my grandbabies
that are being born
with the same midwife that they were
born into the hands of now these
grandbabies are coming into the same
hands and it's just beautiful
as i travel around the us of a i've met
a lot of
homebirthing circles a lot of the
midwives
and there is just
no
substitute for what this state has and
the freedom that we have
and
if i can say one thing about the small
number of midwives there are many more
student midwives that interact with
these midwives
that they support
and another thing is please let the
midwives be midwives
with women
those long drive times i get that
like they don't need extra drive time so
if there's anything you can do to help
you know simplify that so they have more
time
anyways so
i guess we'll leave it with that if
there's any questions i'd be happy
hello my name is sandra holmes i am a
resident of manchester new hampshire i
have had two children my first was
hospital born and my second was at home
hb1061-fn robs midwifery oversight from
people competent to set the standards of
their profession and it puts it into the
hands of people not even competent to
practice the profession
this puts the entire practice of
midwifery into the hands of people who
know nothing about midwifery and who
have a vested interest in the practice
ceasing to exist
changes
to the changing the composition of the
midwifery council from midwives and
their advisors to doctors and one
midwife takes the midwives out of the
driver's seat of their own profession
taking all the power from the midwifery
council
and placing it into the hands of a
single executive director is counter to
new hampshire's values
powers should be vested widely across a
large council not concentrated in the
hands of a single person there is no
need to change the composition of the
eleven months ago while hospitals were
only allowing a single support person
into the labor and delivery room
i gave birth to my daughter in my bed
with my husband and my mother with two
midwives and my teenage son close at
hand able to meet his sister within
moments of her birth i would not have
while hospitals were forcing mothers and
their family member to wear masks
through labor and delivery my daughter
was born into a room with her parents
and brothers and grandmothers unmasked
faces as her first sight
i wouldn't have received that in the
hospital
my midwives ensured the health and
safety of me and my baby and they were
able to whisk us away to a hospital if
it became necessary
giving birth in this fashion was my
choice and my right and it is the right
the passing of hb-1061-fn
can only lead to the reduction of the
medical options available to women in
new hampshire
and that's all i have to say
senior questions thank you for your
hello my name is rebecca pricewood i'm
the owner of sacred transitions
midwifery and we are the practice that
manages
the
monadnock birth center in swansea new
hampshire
my history as a midwife
is um
starting out in texas
i was a midwife there i became a midwife
there i was also a midwife for seven
years in louisiana
served as the president of the louisiana
midwives association for two years
and then five years ago my family moved
up to vermont and i've been a vermont
licensed midwife and a new hampshire
licensed midwife for five years
i come to you today to speak from the
perspective of a person a midwife who
has practiced under a midwifery advisory
council in the state of louisiana
midwives in louisiana got licensure in
1984 and very quickly after that
we
were managed by the medic the board of
medical examiners with an advisory
committee
this is how midwife was midwifery was
regulated in that state until 1999
when um i'm sorry 2012 when the advisory
committee was abolished by governor's
order
so
when i hear uh representatives coming in
and talking about this wasn't the
intention of the bill this wasn't the
intention wasn't to be an assault on the
practice of midwifery in this state
i can tell you
and i think that you all know that
impact of bills and laws trump's
intention and ultimately what is written
in the law and what is written in the
bill takes on a life of its own we've
seen this time and time again i mean
this is not
unique to this bill
so i'm urging all of you to listen to
the voices of the constituents who have
shown up here today mostly women and
their families and i want you to hear
that the impact of midwifery any assault
on this profession
is an assault on the constituents of
this state
that we serve
thank you very much
i must say i drive past there every day
it'll be nice to put a face with the
sorry
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record lindsey
courtney executive director office of
professional licensure and certification
i
by saying thank you to
particularly members of the council who
took time to come here the amount of
collaboration um and respect that
they've shown me in this dialogue as
well as members of the public i think
this has been a very
um it is not it was never my intent um
to
impact the ability of women to receive
care through midwifery others and i've
had extensive conversations with the
midwifery council i had drafted proposed
amendment that i circulated to them
which would effectively change the
composition of the advisory council
as well as require a greater
collaboration in the statute
the
concerns that have been raised are
really
[Music]
the one thing that's missing here i
think is really the the
justification
for the initial part of the bill
i'm just going to draw the committee's
attention to
my written testimony in which i laid out
the
united states supreme court's decision
in north carolina state board of dental
examiners versus federal trade
commission
i don't agree with that opinion i
actually agree with a dissenting opinion
but unfortunately there's no mechanism
to appeal a decision of the united
states supreme court so it is what it is
and essentially what that case said was
when you have a state regulation
comprised primarily of active market
participants
which is which is the model we have in
new hampshire and obviously the general
court chose wisely
prior to the 2015 case
when that happens
and they
make decisions either through licensure
or through regulation
or through investigation of complaints
that that decision is subject to
antitrust scrutiny and there is no
immunity under the state
if there's no state supervision which we
have done here
the state is absolutely 100 gonna be
sued at some point i fully believe that
whether it's warranted or not as a prior
litigator
this bill is really intended to be
proactive
we've got 27 licensees so the risk is
greater for in particular for this board
because everybody knows each other
i think there's probably more members of
the public here than are actually
regulated by the council
so i think we need to have this
conversation
with that backdrop
um
of course the supreme court recognized
that the state is free to choose not to
immunity under the sherman act and if
the state would like to keep such a
model um
then that's the state's prerogative
but
it is a significant concern i have
um it's a significant concern that i
think we should all have because i just
want to play this out
if we if the state is sued by the ftc
and i have no doubt at some point that
the feds will file a lawsuit
and we will either be forced into some
sort of consent decree
where we completely take away the
ability to regulate the professions in
the manner that the state has chosen
um or essentially it'll go to trial and
the judge will choose to do the same
i would like to see new hampshire retain
its ability to determine what type of
occupational licensing structure it
should have
but at some point i think as we've seen
in other states north carolina and other
states i think that we're going to be
i'd be happy to answer any questions
i'm sure
there are some
the notion of an advisory council is not
something i just dreamt up
we have that model in place here for
certain boards already
that is the model that other states
utilize
including vermont
there is a way for the boards and
members of the profession and members of
administration to work collaboratively
with each other to ensure that the
expertise is appropriately leveraged
that members of the profession have an
active voice and
in
the regulations that are put into place
while at the same time providing
sufficient state oversight
to ensure that the state is not uh
potentially risking any liability for
any decisions that could that could
potentially be argued or viewed as
anti-competitive in nature and whether
they are or they're not it doesn't
matter because as we all know
you can file a lawsuit against anything
um so in any event happy to take any
questions that's you have my written
testimony that's the crux of
the gist of this bill
representative lekis
thank you um
so given
those are your goals i'm i'm wondering
how that led to the
changes in the membership of the
advisory council which
i saw as and i think other people here
have seen is one of the most concerning
parts of this i agree and i'll and i'll
be completely honest with you
representative as i was with the council
i didn't fully appreciate the um
history there
um essentially all of our current
advisory councils have three members
so when drafting this i just picked the
you know different types of people that
are currently serving on the committee
i the amendment that i've drafted for
consideration i passed to the council
would have ex would expand that include
the pediatrician the obstetrician the
three midwifery council members
um
you know i think it's important to note
though that at some point every member
of this every licensee is going to be on
the board
because there's only 27 of them so i
think that's why
representative marsh
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my questions gordon here
i'm looking at the supreme court's
opinion in the case of north carolina
state board of dental examiners versus
the ftc
and it appears that this case began
when the board issued cease and desist
orders to non-dentists who were
providing teeth whitening services at a
lower cost
than the dentists were offering would
you not agree that that is substantially
different than what's going on with
midwifery in the state of new hampshire
where the midwives are providing their
services at substantially lower costs
than their competitors being on being
hospital births
i would agree that case had different
facts but i do not agree that the ftc's
ability to
essentially look into antitrust matters
or antitrust law generally is limited to
to those circumstances
and i can give you a long list of
examples of observations we've made in
board meetings
um where
and you'll see that the supreme court
recognized that you can't as a
professional and i'll say the same is
true for myself as a lawyer it's hard to
take off that hat
and i think what the supreme court
recognized is inherent
in
the ability to
regulate
whether implicit or otherwise
you're going to you're going to be
swayed by your personal um
experience particularly as a business
owner this is this is more of a concern
right when people in their business
you know for example
if a board
were to impose
regulations
limiting let's say the dental board were
to impose regulations
limiting the ability of a qualified
anesthesiologist
to provide anesthesia services in a
dental care practice
because it would
protect the public but actually uh
protect the business of the dental
anesthesia providers i think that's
something the ftc could look into
and yet that's exactly some of the
things that we've observed
so i don't think it's limited to the
facts that were laid out in that case
i think there's a lot of
soft decisions that are made that we see
um that are
at times driven by the other hat that
people are wearing and that's not to say
that there's
that's you know these are people right
they wear different hats i wear many
different hats and i think that's what
the supreme court recognizes that it's
very hard to take all hats off and so
there needs to be some state supervision
in order for the state to claim immunity
i'll give you another example i think i
gave it to you earlier the body art
body artists wanted a bill to allow
estheticians to be able to perform
microblading we got the bill
then they got a bunch of calls saying ah
that's going to ruin my business so they
decided no we're not going to write
rules well there's sufficient state
supervision because they're an advisory
board so i was able to say no we're
going to move forward with rulemaking
and please provide me with
recommendations
and they did
that's a that's an issue that if we
didn't have that model
um they certainly wouldn't have
regulated
and i have no doubt that the
estheticians who are quite vocal you
know would have would have been
concerned about that those are the types
representative grota
thank you this morning when we heard
house bill 1059
which was related to
creating the position of
advisory boards for those you i'm sorry
positioner for the executive director of
oplc
in consultation with the advisory board
how would how does this situation differ
um this situation is different in the
sense that what motivated a plc to
pursue this bill was not a lack of
quorum it's more of just the really
small size of the industry
and or the profession and the fact that
i think because of its small size it's
at higher risk for scrutiny
on an anti-trust level everybody knows
each other
okay follow-up please follow up
do we have any other similar
boards that could fall under this
issue yes um
you have a court reporter's bill in
front of you but that that board
actually has
the two issues they're not meeting as a
forum and there's only 60 people who are
regulated
my current one of our current advisory
boards reflexology
uh there's also i think only 29
licensees and so that's why that model
works out well
um we so the advisory boards generally
thank you
representative fellows
thank you i i have two questions
um
one of them is aren't there any sort of
laws
in existence in statute maybe not in the
oplc section
that protect the state to be against
being sued for this kind of thing
well you they would be immune
if they were state supervision that's
exactly what the supreme court case said
that the state officials who are
arguably acting in an antitrust
manner
could be immune from suit and liability
if the state had actively supervised
them and that means that somebody who's
not part of the marketplace a member of
the profession it has the capacity to
essentially
vet their decision-making process
so that's exactly what this issue is
about there's
in my opinion
um there's no state supervision
therefore you know for our 50 licensing
boards if one of them were to make a
decision
um or regulate in such a manner that
could be perceived as keeping people out
of the marketplace
because they want to retain business
whether or not it's valid or not
um
this state would be liable um potential
the state would be liable
representative fellows
you you're recognized for follow-up but
if you could please bring your
microphone closer to you because we
can't hear anything that you're saying
thank you
representative likeliest you'll be after
after representative fellows
um
so
uh
why isn't that the the staff that you
provide that you provide legal advice
and
administrative support to the boards why
isn't that enough
to
qualify for supervision and my second
question is can you just tell me the
difference between a board and a council
regarding the letter there's really not
a difference
we've got boards councils and
commissions they all function in the
same way
regarding the former um
providing assistance and administrative
support to does not constitute
supervision supervision according to the
supreme court connotes some sort of
to
be part of the decision making i will
say
whereas providing support
does not
and
speaking not specifically to the council
it's quite common for a plc to provide
legal advice and that's not that doesn't
go that's not heated so um
representative lekas
thank you um
sort of related i understand your
concern um
and so
you know what what i'm trying to get and
i i've got a question here is
how can we let the midwives regulate
midwifery
while having some state supervision
to prevent them from getting in legal
antitrust trouble
and and
related to that is in the other language
we had elsewhere where it says oplc
executive director can do something
with the um advice of the board the
question is what does that really mean
where's the power who has control over
what
so with advice of the board means that i
have to seek out advice of the board but
ultimately the agency is the decision
maker
that provides sufficient state
supervision but it also underlies the
concerns that that professionals have
which is that the professionals don't
have complete control over the
profession
so this this bill
is one way
of
you know threading the needle so to
speak and trying to
i think meet justifiable concerns
regarding uh liability
but i think that the the council members
of the council other also proposed other
language
i'm not sure that that would
i'm not sure if that would actually
satisfy north carolina dental's
analysis i'd have to go back and take a
look
the agency is not i mean the agency will
work with the council work with members
of the legislature in order to get to a
point where all
all concerns are satisfied
so
you know would it satisfy do you think
you know the the legal requirement if
there was some kind of language that
said that uh
that didn't give oplc any
control over the the practice
um you know what what's required to be a
midwife or or all that
other than specifically to um
that you know you could provide legal
advice on whether or not this conflicts
with
you know whatever the wording would be
you know anti-trust law
um and that that would be
yeah so so presently the state
presently the state has the capacity
through the attorney general right to
direct state officials to do certain
things
um
in my experience that's not often that
doesn't regularly occur
um
because it usually has to get really bad
in order for that to happen and even
then
i haven't observed that happen
frequently
you could certainly have some sort of
statutory requirement but the issue that
we're running into
and i'm not speaking specifically to the
midwifery council is that there there
are certain boards am i a very small
minority
that regardless of what the statute says
they continue to do something in controv
contravention of the statute i can't
force somebody
to do something that they don't want to
do
so i think one thing the state could do
under the supreme court case the supreme
court case could have i mean the state
could have a clear policy favoring
anti-competitive regulation i don't
think the state wants to do that and i
wouldn't recommend it but that would
satisfy the concerns
you could have some sort of veto
authority by a different body whether it
be me or the legislature
certain decisions i think that would
help i think that would satisfy
and meet the requirements for state
supervision i think there are a couple
of different ways we could get there
but ultimately you need somebody who's
not a member of the profession who can
essentially veto certain decisions
that's i think what the case gets at and
i think
i think that's what the general court
needs to be aware of just generally with
our structure
okay i'd like to see if we can work
towards that whether it's this bill or
representative grota did you have a
question
representative black is asked it so
never going to get house broken
um
is uh i this is actually a question
prompted by what i've been hearing for
miss um asa is she still here
uh
you were on the you were on the council
right
and you were the consumer member how
okay
see no further hands the witnesses
excused thank you
at this time we will
close the public hearing for house bill
1061.
my apologies i didn't ask if there was
if everybody could would please accept
my apology i did not ask if there were
any more members of the public that
wished to speak in there and we did have
one
i am reopening the hearing for house
bill 1061
i apologize and thank you all for the
opportunity to still speak my name is
therese grinnell i'm a registered nurse
i live in loudoun new hampshire
i come to you
from kind of the opposite side of the
situation
as far as being part of a medical
practice that is overseen by the oplc
and all i want to say is you know
hearing that this is because of a
concern that the state might be sued
we have to take a step back and look at
what's really truly right for
our patients our mothers and our babies
i can tell you right now what's
happening in healthcare that is overseen
by oplc there's over 60
licensed clinicians that zoom call with
that i'm a part of on a weekly basis
right now
that are feeling very very um
tied to doing what they used to be able
to do for their patients
for example the autonomy to prescribe a
medication
they actually have emails from their
employers that say if you prescribe this
you will be fired we have patients that
are in the icu
and we're requesting basic interventions
that were always protocol with a patient
in the icu for daily labs right you
would think you would get daily labs in
the icu
tpn total parental nutrition for someone
who's been in the hospital for over six
days they're not getting nutrition basic
things that were always a practice of
health care
we are now told
in a video by dartmouth-hitchcock at 302
that if you do anything outside of what
the administrators have deemed the
protocol
you will be disciplined
with me ma'am is this relative to it it
is
yes it is i'm getting right to it i
promise
um individuals who
are are practicing what's in the best
interest of their patient in that moment
are being
stifled and it's costing lives
so
if we could somehow have the combination
of the oversight to protect the state
like we do now where they are
collaborating but you allow the autonomy
of those providers to do what they need
to do in that moment with their
experience
when they've gone through the schooling
the testing the licensure
and everything else without now what's
happening
is the federal government
is dictating
what people can do
in a way we've never seen before
so that's my concern as we discern that
these associations for midwifery
reflexology
whatever it might be come under these
umbrellas the government overreach
in my opinion and what i'm seeing in the
last two years has actually cost lives
so we just need to be aware that
as we over regulate as government
overreaches
there is the potential for things to be
done
that are not
done in a collective professional
decision making but rather in the fear
of litigation and that's that's that
just can be very dangerous
thank you for your time i oppose this
bill
thank you
at this time i will close the public
uh we are of course 45 minutes i didn't
fine we are way beyond the time
requested for this bill the bill is
going to sub-committee
all of you are welcome to send us your
your thoughts or listen or visit the
subcommittee and tell us what you think
i
i think i will not let you reopen it
again
okay
i'm opening the hearing on house bill 10
30 and i representative edwards will
present it
and if you are exiting the room because
you're not interested please leave
quietly
by apologies
i was happy to have representative
edwards backing me up but i i i don't
good afternoon
edna i am for the record representative
steve pearson rockingham district six
dairy
house bill 1030
is what we would call a repair bill
this is based on a piece of legislation
that was passed
in a prior session that inadvertently
omitted two branches of the united
states military
that was something that was discovered
during
the process and frankly we were told
that the senate was going to make those
corrections
and they clearly did not
so all this bill does is it
it adds the coast guard
and
air force marine corps and coast guard
into the
list of military or department of
defense branches
that
would qualify for the equivalency into
the lna field
i'm i'm not entirely sure
if the emails that came to me came to
all of you but there was some question
in reference to the space force not
being included the medics in the space
force fall under the u.s air force they
do not have their own space force
medical corps
so therefore they are not included
beyond that like i said this is merely
just a housekeeping bill to
place the branches of the military back
or into the statute that were omitted
thank you are there any questions
seeing on thank you very much thank you
madam chair
uh thank you madam chair representative
jess edwards representing auburn chester
and sandown
um i
i meant to be supporting uh
representative pearson in his uh
presentation of this so i'm there's some
risk of some redundancy but
um i've been following this bill with
interest for
a couple of years now since it started
with the air force and army recognizing
their medical training their enlisted
medical training
and
we noticed kind of early on that the
marines and navy had been overlooked and
i think it's just because the bill's
authors
hadn't
understood
how the marines used the navy corpsmen
and and so it just got overlooked and we
wanted to make sure that
that this bill
could
self-adapt over time
so
we used the phrase on line seven
or others meaning
the department of defense
space command will be one of the
department of defense and however they
in the next decade decide to staff their
medic
enlisted pool whether it be air force or
however they do it this bill should be
intended to be flexible enough to adapt
automatically over time without rewrite
i'm a little uncomfortable putting
things in there like
a specific military occupational skill
like 68 whiskey because when i went into
the army many decades ago those were
called 91 bravos so i just would hate to
see the
you know law get weird because the dod
changes mosses but i think that's fine
for now we can we can just watch it and
i don't know what a four november
zero
x-ray one is but i did look it up on the
internet and it seems to be the correct
nomenclature
[Music]
i think i think this is uh really an
important bill we already passed the
bill in concept last year we want to
recognize the military training
and bring those
young men and women into our health care
provider professions
thank you very much i agree with you
completely and i like that you've got or
equivalent
widely
spread out through the bill so we can
avoid having to do this again
any questions from the committee
all right seeing none thank you very
much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1030
okay seeing none
i'm going to close the hearing on house
bill 1030
open the hearing on house bill 1427
thank you madam chair
i'm representative sally fellows from
holderness
last year when we passed hb2
that included a section
that combined
two boards the the board of speech
pathology and i'm not sure the exact
title but the board that that had to do
with audiologists and hearing aid
dealers
in the process of doing that
the language
neglected to include an audiologist
so this is a
correction to make sure that there's at
least one audiologist on the board that
oversees audiologists
so that's
all this bill does
any questions
are there questions from the committee
seeing none i
thank you very much representative
fellows
uh
good afternoon representative mcguire
and members of the committee
my name is carolyn drury i'm an
audiologist
who has been certified and licensed in
the state of new hampshire since 1983
and have actively worked as such
for 38 years until my recent retirement
at the end of june last year
i am here to testify in support of hb
1427 on behalf of the new hampshire
academy of audiology
the purpose of the amendment is to have
both an audiologist and a hearing aid
dealer sitting on this board
as these are different providers by
training and definition
within new hampshire state law
the rsa 326 f
the new speech language pathology and
hearing aid providers practice board has
merged the two
so that they are now on board but they
have carried forward the definitions of
the profession providers
from the original
rsa
137f
just briefly to run through that
audiologists are college and or
university trained in the auditory
system diagnostic testing and assessment
of hearing disorders and their treatment
for both children and adults
this encompasses fitting of appropriate
assistive equipment
including hearing aids so we our scope
of practice includes that as well
hearing aid dealers are simply trained
to perform a basic test for the purpose
of selling hearing aids they are
business people who do this as part of
their livelihood
but the training is quite different and
we
work in different areas predominantly
audiologists are in medical centers
doctors offices there are some who work
in contracts with the school system
for youngsters
and we also have private practice people
as well
hearing aid dealers tend to be in
private practice or work for some of the
large
nationally franchised chains for hearing
aids
and there's primarily business people
um that's don't want to go too much more
than that
the other comment i have as i'm aware
that the board has not actually met
since its inception
in july
and we the new hampshire academy of
audiology has provided two names for
members qualified members to sit on that
board and as yet that position has not
been filled and we're a little
frustrated by that and we'd like to look
forward to trying to get things moving
along
um thank you for your time attention and
considering did i understand you
correctly to say that the board has not
met the new board has not met and that
there are qualified
personnel been recommended by your
organization that have not been
appointed to the board yes no one has
been appointed yet thank you very much
you're welcome
are there other questions
representative scitec
uh you say that you have um
written testimony yes there are 25
copies of their andy please yeah i have
them
i've got all of them here do i just walk
up to them other questions
okay seeing none thank you for your
testimony
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee lindsay courtney executive
director oplc
um this bill is pretty clear uh this was
a request that we made
in order to clarify that both an
audiologist and hearing aid dealer
should be represented on the board as
oplc believes that professionals should
have input into the regulation of their
professions
i'm happy to take any questions if the
committee has any but other than that i
think this bill is pretty
straightforward
i do have a question i noticed that
you're making the board six members
so quorum is now four
and
you have the possibility of ties
true
um
i think we would we would welcome an
amendment to make it an odd number
are
but we're a little concerned with
growing committees because we're already
having issues with uh obtaining members
so
we wouldn't we wouldn't want to make the
committee so large i suppose seven would
be
okay
it's still pretty big but given the
profession but
but obviously we would support an
amendment to make it an odd number of
individuals
thank you all right seeing none
is there anyone else who wishes to
i just wanted to add one piece of
information based on
what we heard
i know that um
someone was nominated to be on the board
back in i think it was october the the
governor made a nomination but then for
reasons we don't need to go into
that nomination was withdrawn so you
know just to show you that there has
been an attempt to
get more people on the board and
i could also share that
there was
some people
i heard from constituents
that wished that there were two
audiologists on the board
just in case one was not available so if
we want to increase the number that
would be one way to do it make it two
audiologists instead of one
thank you representative fellows are
there other questions
okay thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing seeing none i'm going
to close the public hearing
and
what am i doing you're chairing the
all right good afternoon we're going to
open the public hearing on house bill
1016 and i call the sponsor of the bill
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire
representing merrimack 29 allenstown
epsom in pittsfield
and house bill 6 1016
is an attempt to
address a problem we found
in the medicare for schools program
where it was determined that a fair
number
of the speech language
professionals in the school systems were
some of them were given
most of them are given temporary
licenses
a good number of them qualified
for a regular license some others don't
and those were
different
profession different education they did
graduate level training
in various issues
but not necessarily the ones specified
by the speech language pathologists
so
this bill expands the
people with that
alternate education
to get so that they can get an
appropriate license
and it was
i'm not sure it was a request of jail
educa or the department of education or
oplc but it was
very good thank you
representative mcguire um i'll start
i'll start with if you're willing to
take questions i'll just start with a
simple one
just looking at this
as it now creates a
paragraph b and move c back so this is
now
taking the requirement of a master's
degree and now allowing folks with a
bachelor's degree to
be licensed in this profession is that
the essence of this
sir okay it allows people with a
bachelor's degree in speech language
pathology or similar
plus a master's degree in some other
related related field for example
special ed early childhood education if
you're going to concentrate on young
children
learning disabilities things like that
so that you have some training
the bachelor's level of speech language
pathology plus an additional master's in
some in a related field
does anyone on the committee have any
questions for representative mcguire
hmm
i'll follow my own advice please turn
there's a button near the bottom
and
there you go
oh
okay
live in 58 barry road and loud new
hampshire
i think i might be providing some
testimony
that i'm not sure if you already have so
i don't know if i'm going to be a little
ahead of what you already know or what's
in you in front of you
so my background pertains to
my personal professional affiliations is
i'm the past president of new hampshire
speech language hearing association
past president and vice president of
governmental affairs
a past member of the speech pathology
licensing board from the department of
allied health
and i also was a past member for the
committee of
three renewal of speech specialist rule
rules with the department of education
um and i that was somewhere in like the
mid-2000s so
um that's what i've got for my
background and i was probably on the
initial board for about 12 years from
about 1999 to about 2012
i am in opposition to this bill and i'll
explain why
um
i'm going to start off by showing you
this chart that was put together by
nishala
and it's got 2004 and 2007.
and the reason why nishla the new
hampshire speech language hearing
association put this chart together is
because
there was so much confusion among who a
speech
provider was in the public schools
and the different routes to
our avenues to getting that
certification or job in the school so to
speak was extremely confusing to the
consumer
the people who are parents of children
who receive these services in schools
so
pretty much everything here is similar i
have
the qualifications for a speech
pathologist who is licensed under the
governing
department of allied health
the speech specialist under the
department of ed
the alternative for that was
offered and i think still is as far as
an avenue to get certified through the
department of ed
and then speech language pathology
assistance the only difference on here
now is that
speech pathology assistants or speech
assistants are now
under
the governing the speech pathology
governing board and regulated by them at
the time this hadn't been um
official yet it was a pending so that's
different and you can have this
up here talks about all the different
disorders or
speech
disorders and diseases and
issues that people work with
in the profession and it's not just
schools
it is in all areas however just to
mention
the school population
is just inundated or has a high
population of severely impaired children
that does require
a graduate degree in the area of
communication sciences endorsed
disorders and speech pathology
so these are significant disorders and i
have them all listed here and i'll just
as a summary there's things like
neurogenic disorders like strokes
aphasia swallowing
augmentative communication
and um and these are children that that
have these
these disorders and disabilities in
schools as well but this is from way
back when and because
routine calls from parents because they
would find out
after a while that their child was not
being treated or serviced or through
their iep by a qualified professional
and that qualified professional or that
qualified employee or that employee
was the type of person that this bill is
recommending to license it was a person
that had an undergraduate degree but did
not have
a graduate degree that is considered
the highest level of standard with the
american speech language hearing
association
and the
licensure um
so i don't know if you've i i got a
memorandum that is from vicki chester
lee that she
was had submitted i don't know if you're
familiar with it
at this point
so
i know she's going to be here to testify
and i went through her report
or her memorandum and i wanted to bring
up some points that i'm
have learned with the research i have
done
and
one of the points that i want to make on
this on her report
is that vicki is currently not on the
board of the new hampshire speech
language hearing association she has
been such as myself
but i have a concern that this is on
the
nishla letterhead
however anishla executive board board
member has not submitted this to this
committee
i know there's an amendment that was
done
and the department of ed is here to
speak to that and what i know about that
amendment is because
our national organization in asha saw
that the original
house bill 106
it brought grave concern because what
it's about to do is bring this back to
the convolution that everybody has dealt
with
so a little bit of background that i
want to clarify in the memorandum that
you have
is that yes in the 1970s the degree
program was
clinically based
and
certification or working in public
schools was
was typical and accepted
i would a graduate degree and a master's
degree in speech pathology or
has been the required degree
and this state has well over a thousand
if not more
speech pathologists who are sort of who
are
who have that degree who are working in
the schools
so i'm saying 40 years
has gone by where people who have a
bachelor's degree had the decision to
either get a graduate degree in speech
pathology
or
they can
the um
the and then this criteria that i have
down here to get admission into that
program so in the early 1990s licensure
was enacted in new hampshire so um
from there is when there was a divide
some of the people who were already
currently
certified in the public schools
were not going to
or not did not want to go under
licensure when it was enacted in the
early 90s i don't remember the exact
date
but they decided that they wanted to
stay with the department of ed and be
certified under there and that is how
the speech-language specialist
nomenclature came about because they
couldn't be called speech pathologists
because of the other thing
so from 1996 to 2001 the university of
new hampshire provided a master's in
science
in teaching communication disorders due
to the ida requirements
so that the people who did have the
but did not have the master's degrees
were able to
keep their jobs and sustain sustain
their jobs in the school
so here's the program it no longer
exists because it's just gone by these
these people have the opportunity or it
was put there for that very reason so
here's the program that unh had that was
called the masters in teaching program
that would certify the sls
many people took advantage of that many
many people who took advantage of that
program
this had a bachelor's degree they got
this degree
but that was well after
the 1970s we're talking about in the
1990s
that people were doing this program
taking this program so they're fairly
recent graduates
but now we're talking about probably 30
years since the licensure has been acted
the qualifications and the criteria has
been
clearly
established and if you look in the
the um there's
there's thousands of speech pathologists
here that are working
so this is not anything new
the grad the undergraduate degrees the
people they don't even really exist
anymore it's it's like a dinosaur
um
so these this this degree cannot bridge
over into the american speech language
hearing association to get certified
um and that was as recent as a
conversation with susan adams who
participated in the amendment
um and just to clarify that because i
so that so so what i'm going to just
talk about is some of that's one part of
the memorandum to clarify those dates
and what has occurred and transpired
and then in paragraph two it's it states
to
you can eliminate the endorsement that a
licensed slp and sls
have the endorsement of the department
of ed although it's not rigorously
enforced
the speech language specialist rules
that's here
we
their rsa that anybody who holds a
speech pathology degree
uh anybody who's a speech pathologist by
the governing board of speech language
pathology shall be considered to have
met the requirements never in my over 25
26 whatever years i've been working have
i ever had to get certified as a speech
language
specialist at the school i've only had
to have the speech pathology because
that was the the optimal
um
certification
to work in the school
so that that's in here and it's it's not
a fact it's not true it doesn't have to
happen it's not something that has
happened
um
the other part one of the um
um to this memorandum
um
it that that was to require the meets um
the requirements for that on paragraph
three
um
i'm just stating that it was says asha
has objected to licensing these
individuals the individuals are these
undergraduate people
who this bill is trying to
allow to be licensed with degrees that
are maybe in reading early childhood
special education
those types of things not
a master of science degree and
communication disorders
and i'll just tell you my experiences as
i see children because i work with very
young children i would work with all
ages
but when they are not treated by a
person who has the competency
they're not making the gains in progress
and parents don't even know who these
people are or their qualifications
very often
but to bring about
allowing licensed people
to allowing these
undergraduates to be licensed and then
say they're licensed
now when they
when parents are in an iep meeting
and they think this person is licensed
it's actually deceiving when they don't
have the same
degree and expertise and knowledge that
the
slp has maybe in this district's next
building
so this is very very gray
and it's
it's going to just confuse the public
and it's not protecting the consumer
um
so i am not in support of this bill
because
the educational and academic internship
training is not the same
as as in an undergraduate undergraduate
degree
with an educational master's degree
described in the memorandum by victoria
chester lee
the count of
cms
center for medicaid
and
medicare
their rules
that you can review
require that
the person is qualified the quiet the
qualified person
has these degrees
they have these higher degrees that i'm
mentioning to you right now that is by
medicaid for schools
and medicaid
by the federal government
so i don't understand how a person with
an undergraduate degree without the
higher standard of the graduate degree
is actually going to be able to
fulfill the medicaid requirement maybe
it's something i need to learn but i'm
just going by the documentation
from
and
um medicaid to schools only began
probably in the
late 1990s when i was working as a
school slp
so that has been fairly recent meaning
that by that time these undergraduate
people whoever aware they are
if they were working under another
capacity or with a different degree
a speech pathologist with an asha
certification and licensure would sign
their
documentation for delivery of services
and the school would receive their
medicaid funds for that child
but it had to be signed off by the
qualified provider which was
the asha certified that i've said a
million times that you might be tired of
hearing
um
anyway
so that that is that is not new i mean
this has been the past 30 years i don't
know where these undergraduates who from
the 1970s are coming from who are not
where they are i mean
hopefully they're retired but
in any case um
um
you know the the we these people that
people who are
in europe to see to
adhere that people are going to be
protected and that they get the right
service deliveries
the other thing is is that i looked at
the counterparts of my team members
which are occupational therapists
physical therapists
and they have pretty stringent
guidelines for reimbursement for
medicaid
and there isn't anything that says that
a you know physical ed teacher could do
pt
medicaid reimbursement or something of
that example
i
i think that it is uh
a lot of progress because i understand
there's somebody from the department of
ed that's going to speak here in favor
of
this and maybe
i heard supporting eliminating the
speech specialist
um
certification under the department of ed
and it that i would wholeheartedly agree
with and i think that it's there should
be less convolution and i know that
ashes supports having only one body
be in the state
to um be certified or
the credentialed person for this
position
but as i said i was on a committee a
long time ago i know the department of
it has a lot of changes in there with
different people who are no longer there
but my
experience is that the allied health and
department of ed have never worked
together
uh i think it's gonna
be
quite an endeavor
for
the department of eds who
relinquished this certification and i
also know that they've held on to it
they've loved it
and i i'd be surprised if they if they
actually if this changes but that would
be a good thing
i don't think it should be at the
uh the undergraduate
who you
i don't have the requirements for an
undergraduate degree with me but you can
easily find them on the unh website but
their coursework
is just very basic
and their degrees in another area does
not touch upon any of these
criteria or disorders that are happening
in the public schools
i have these papers that i can give to
this committee
and i can leave them with you
and other documentations that i refer to
and the cms rules
and i if
i strongly suggest that
you review this carefully
if you know anybody in the profession
a neighbor or a relative
i would ask them their opinion before
this huge change takes place
and people like myself have to start
re-explaining
why they have a person who's not
qualified working with their child
um
so thank you for the opportunity and if
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman i actually don't
have a question if i could just have one
second that might clear up um
a few things
actually just one thing
you had mentioned
medicaid to schools a lot
and
prior to me being elected to be a state
representative i i actually worked in
the special education department at a
local school district and one of the
jobs i had there was actually being the
medicaid coordinator
god help me
um
for those of you that don't know uh
the testimony she gave is actually you
know very much correct that you you did
have to have
uh you know
these these professions had
professionals had to be licensed in
order to sign off on these special
education services in order for the
schools to be reimbursed
and then i believe
i want to say was three years ago it was
at least two years ago
that there was actually
a massive change that was met that was
made to the medicaid to schools program
where it was no longer able to just be
you know the speech pathologist signing
off on the paraprofessionals or her coda
it actually became where you actually
had to have a doctor a registered nurse
practitioner um signing off on these
on these ieps and
yes it
it it created a little bit of of
confusion on
so just wanted to to kind of clarify
the question was would you agree that
i tried to say in the beginning was more
of a statement would you agree that that
has created some confusion for the
medicaid to schools program
well yeah bless you for that doing that
job because doing the whole
doing medicaid to schools is completely
confusing
yeah i would agree with what you're
saying
i also am a medicaid provider as a as a
private practitioner i have a lot of
experience with
commercial reimbursement
for um people that come in for treatment
through their commercial insurance
companies i forgot to add that
uh
a license and with the different
background how is that gonna work when
they when they require a commercial
insurance company
medicaid
enrollment as a provider in the state of
new hampshire
well i'm licensed and i have other you
know other certificate my other
certification
but how is that going to
be delineated for somebody who's
licensed with the undergraduate degree
how is that going to be able to be i'm
just bringing it out rhetorically but
how is that going to be
monitored how how i realized that the
amendment has some really good
safeguards in place
but
i've been on the licensing board i mean
even that's hard to monitor people
so
if i may mr chairman i
i'm not exactly sure if i'm
i'm certainly not an expert in this in
this field um
and unfortunately our school that i that
i worked with ended up doing away with
the medicaid to schools program but if
if i'm not
mistaken
basically what happened with the other
schools in the area that kept it
they actually hired
registered nurse practitioners to come
in or or some physicians some of them
actually came in you know our school
meets on tuesdays for their special
education meetings so those particular
professionals would actually come in and
sit
for the special education meeting
and therefore they'd be able to sign off
that yes these services are required
is basically how it ended up going and
then after that
other schools are basically
emailing and or faxing the iep to
the medical professional they're signing
off yes these these services are
required and then from there i believe
that the
you know in this case the speech
pathologist is then able to sign off
saying yes they received the services
that this doctor has agreed
is needed in order to be reimbursed to
the medicaid to schools program did i
answer your question
well partly
first of all i think the practice act
for speech pathology allows the speech
pathologist to not require an ordering
physician
[Music]
although i have to take that back that
that's medicaid they do so they need to
have the pcp
as i'm thinking that's correct
other commercial insurances don't um
what i was bringing about is that
um now that
if the undergraduate person is licensed
as a just a licensed
clinician under the governing board
that
gives them the
um credential
to
not just do medicaid or sign off or on
medicaid to schools and actually you're
saying that we need to have the
physician anyway no
okay
well anyway mike my other person my
other
point on this is aside from medicaid to
schools and working in a school if the
license is convoluted that you have a
a speech pathologist who has the
graduate degree
of the highest level degree and then you
have
a speech licensed speech pathologist who
has an undergraduate degree that has
minimal minimal minimal
requirements
to be able to fulfill the job and a
degree in reading or something how is
that going to be delineated to the
public
if they both have a license
i don't have to show my license to
anybody
it doesn't have a special color to it
that says i've got this degree and this
person doesn't have that degree i have
to provide that license number through
other means
to so that and then they can verify it
but that's that's a lot of a lot of um
red tape or
layers to go through to to to prove that
somebody's actually licensed with a
qualified degree
um
and i
think i don't know if anybody's provided
the qualifications for the master's
level degree i don't know if there's
time to do that after this committee i
can certainly do that i've actually put
things together
very quickly i work like five days a
week 12 hours a day
and i've got a typos on here that i'm
going to fix up and give back to you but
and i'll give you these documents
but
those are the questions that i have and
the reason why i have them is because
those are the questions that i had to
answer and find out about and i know
that people will be coming into my
office asking me what does this mean
and
it's something to be strongly
considered
before
agreeing to this and finding out exactly
how it will affect everything
with the consumer
and that's what the licensing board is
about to protect the consumer
any other questions i appreciate your
testimony thanks on this matter thank
you thanks
if i can have a moment with um
representative mcguire i i there's no
one's going to be shocked here that i
have a direct line to the chairman of
health and human services
uh since he since he's my father um
and they are willing to take this
bill this this to me
appears to be not really about licensing
but about qualifications under our
thank you mr chairman i apologize for
not having written testimony i was not
originally going to testify but i
decided i needed to
i am speaking in opposition to house
bill 1016 as originally drafted in
support of amendment 0091h
which was my attempt to rewrite the bill
and i'm going to tell you guys a story
i can't believe how old i am
34 years ago my oldest daughter was born
in wolfeboro
and like most young parents we brought
her to the public school to begin her
educational process
when becky went to public school i'm
sorry i didn't intend to put her name
into the record
when my oldest daughter went into the
public school the only person in the
world who could understand what she said
was her older brother
she worked with a speech specialist at
the school over the course of her first
year there in kindergarten
and at the end of the year she really
had not made any progress and we were
given the choice of the iep process
and we said no
we
removed her from the system
we found ourselves a speech-language
pathologist in sanford maine who had the
credentials
who diagnosed my daughter as having
exceedingly rare condition known as
speech apraxia and she worked with her
over the course of a great many years
at the end of the time
my daughter successfully we graduated
her from home school
she went to connecticut college where
she graduated on the dean's list
she now runs her own business in the
state of massachusetts
uh she does theater lights
and she's a fully functional member of
society
i did that entirely on my dime we didn't
ask for the taxpayers dollar to do that
it's important to me that we protect the
credential of speech-language
pathologists because i needed to find
someone with qualifications to help my
daughter
and the school didn't do that
and the person in the school is
capable of taking care of all sorts of
things that were really common she had
experience with but she was not
a fully qualified individual
the speech-language pathologist
eventually went on to become the speech
language pathologist at our local
hospital where i'm a trustee
and there are now many more
speech-language pathologists uh in the
state of new hampshire than there were
at the time
my daughter's 34 now like i said i can't
believe how old i am
consequently i worked with attorney
adams and ols to draft or redraft the
bill
in a way that would preserve the
speech-language pathologist credential
would allow us to
not violate the interstate compact which
has now become
established law in the state of new
hampshire
and would allow speech language
specialists to continue to do what they
are doing they can take care of common
things and they are providing a service
in the schools but they are not
speech-language pathologists and we need
and uh with that i'll conclude my
testimony and i'll be glad to take
questions
thank you representative march
representative lekkis
uh thank you so i'm
glad things worked out for your daughter
my
question
is would
would this amendment
end up requiring that um
the people providing speech therapy in
the schools be
you know the fully qualified speech
language pathologist if because if so my
question is
if the
people who were in the schools at the
time your daughter was having the issue
are qualified to handle most things
would it be
appropriate to require all of them have
greater qualifications when it might be
possible maybe the school should
arrange some something else for your
daughter to
find an appropriate person to help but
if they're not needed from
the vast majority of the kids with
problems is that really the right thing
to do i i think that's a fair question
um
i do worry about misdiagnosis i mean not
everybody has the wherewithal to
basically
stick their finger at the system and and
take their take it under their own
responsibility i'm i'm very happy for my
daughter that we were able to do that
for her and and i i worry that there are
others in this world who could have been
in the same situation
and not had that opportunity
we tried to strike a compromise such
that the people who are currently
working in the schools would be able to
continue working in the schools but the
new hires would have the
uh credentials that are now much more
available than they were at the time
because that seemed like a reasonable
compromise i'm certainly amenable to
hearing some other amendment if you have
some better compromise you wish to
propose
representative fellows
thank you
representative marshall can you it it
seems a little confusing to me
issuing a speech language pathology
license
the the the title says speech language
specialist
one says the board shall issue a speech
language pathologist license
so
uh representative if you could give me a
page in line of what you're referring to
then i could refer to what you're this
is at the very beginning of the bill
you know it's line three the bill is
drafted
introduced yes that's the only thing i
have a copy of i'm sorry i have more
amendments in my folder and perhaps
representative schmidt will hand you one
i passed them out to the committee
earlier today but perhaps i you weren't
here at the time and i didn't get you
well let me see if i can put it this way
so do you know the degree requirements
for a speech language pathologist is
does that require a master's degree
uh there are people in the room who can
answer that question better than i and
yes there is a difference in the
credentials
so
follow-up
yes thank you so since i saw nodding
heads
if we're going to issue
it doesn't make any sense to me
that i i don't even believe there's a is
there such a thing as a bachelor's
degree in speech language pathology i'm
just thinking that it's probably a
master's degree but i don't know
that's my dilemma i agree with you that
the language in the original bill was
incredibly confusing and that was
one of the motivations behind my
amendment which i think you now have in
front of you
okay
thank you i will have to
study this amendment to see if i can
figure this out
does anybody else have a question for
representative marsh
seeing none thank you representative
marsh
the chair calls
madam chair and members of the committee
thank you for your consideration of the
amendment to hb 1016.
i'm president of nashua i've been a
speech language pathologist since 1976
i have served on the new hampshire
i've served on the new hampshire speech
language association's executive board
as president treasurer academic advisor
vp of governmental affairs
and i've also served as a
speech-language pathology member from
new hampshire on the asha advisory
council my most recent employment was as
the director of the slpa program at
nashua community college i've also
worked in schools hospitals both acute
care and rehabilitation and home care
i'm currently retired and i'm not
representing
the new hampshire speech language
hearing association
in this hearing i am
representing myself as a private citizen
the memo that laura
referred to was
a prototype that i wrote
um
as an example when i was working with
the vp of governmental affairs
neil tamiya
i think i said his name wrong but
um
if you have a copy of that please
discard it i did
circulate
a
letter
from me as a
private citizen
um
okay
the issues that i'm hoping will resolve
by the passage of the amendment to hb
1016 are consolidating the governmental
oversight of all individuals providing
speech-language pathology services in
new hampshire into the office
of licensed allied health professionals
having two agencies dealing with the
same profession has caused confusion
to the public and to the profession
passing this bill would also relieve the
department of education
from the necessity of requiring licensed
speech-language pathologists to also
hold the speech-language specialist
endorsement
and the associated monitoring of that
an issue that arose was the conflict
with the audiology speech-language
pathology interstate compact
which was passed when this
initiative was being developed it is
exceptionally important that new
hampshire comply with the requirements
of the compact and the american speech
and hearing association
has suggested that a new license be
issued for speech language specialists
so that it would be a speech language
specialist license administered through
the allied health
office of
licensed allied health professionals
by using the alternative title the
individuals holding that license would
automatically be excluded for any from
the underlying issue is
having
two
governmental bodies
dealing with the same profession
in i think it was 2017
the
department of education had a
subcommittee
that
worked on updating the rules for speech
language specialists
and
the
goal of that committee was to make
rules for the speech language specialist
equal to
the requirements for speech-language
pathologist
at that time the main difference is
that the speech-language pathologist has
to take a national exam and i don't
however the individuals that we are
trying to move over to
allied health
have been in the field for 20 30 40
years
and
the new requirements didn't affect them
anyone coming along now
would
have to meet the new requirements
and
i believe that most people would go for
the license
especially if we eliminate the
credential an issue that arose today was
the medicaid to schools program
and i believe that they have changed the
rule so that speech language
pathologists can sign off and order
but i think they fixed it
um
i'm not sure that i said this but the
memo lore was referred to was not
submitted and if you do have it please
discard it
it was
something that
the vp of governmental affairs and i
were working on together
and
memo on that
representative fellows
thank you do you know if there's um the
department of education still has a
certification first
for speech language assistant
no the department of education never had
a um
an endorsement for speech language
assistance that was always done through
the office of allied
done through what um
oplc
does anyone else from the committee have
a question
seeing none thank you ma'am for your
from the new hampshire department of
education
good afternoon representatives thank you
for your time this afternoon for the
record stephen appleby director educator
could you spell your last name we didn't
catch that
yes last name is applebee a-p-p
l-e-b-y
okay
one of the programs that i am
responsible for is educator licensure in
our k-12 system
and to that end i'm here to address
strictly department of education related
questions
um
just some quick facts and figures for
the committee
we currently license over 28 000
educators statewide
in positions ranging from para educators
to superintendents
we have approximately 88 different
endorsements that we license
of that over 28 000 we currently license
less than 60 speech language specialists
and when we looked at this issue and
analyzed it about 18 months ago when the
medicaid to schools issue was was a very
big topic
what we found was
our sls
base of that less than 60 less than 20
were not speech language pathologists
and that less than 20 number the average
one other piece of information
every year i receive numerous phone
asking why
this speech language pathologist calling
us asking why they have to pay the
department of education for a license
as well as oplc for a license
so we support
moving this entirely to oplc in whatever
form that takes we're not medical
professionals we're educators
but
the follow-up question to the dual
licensure is always well physical
therapists and occupational therapists
don't need an education license why do i
so hence hence the support for moving
this
to oplc
i have concerns about
us
operating in the state with speech
language pathologists and speech
language specialists
i
i'm confused as hell by it i can't
imagine how someone from the general
public is going to be how does the
department of education
what would the department of education
look for what would you guys be using
would you be looking for pathologists or
specialists
so
we have not licensed a new
speech-language specialist
that was not also a speech-language
pathologist in many years predates my
time coming to the department
so the only folks today getting licenses
from the department of education are
already slps
and as evidenced by our administrative
rule which states that you know here's a
list of competencies to be an sls
or
if you have a valid speech language
pathologist license we will take that in
your fee and we will issue you a license
as an sls
so
we don't see an influx of folks coming
in to get an sls license who aren't
already an slp
so i guess what i'm saying here is it's
okay thank you representative fellows
thank you
so since
so you so the schools want to employ
speech language pathologists
and
you would like to see them be licensed
by oplc
don't you also need to certify them
because one of the things we heard in a
in an earlier bill is that
oplc
um
doesn't
do or has
difficulty with doesn't know how to
really you know have good ideas for
handling backgrounds criminal background
checks which is very important in
schools
so how how would you make sure that they
don't have
that criminal record so you don't want
them in schools thank you
thank you for the question um
up
until this past legislative session we
did not criminal record check
license holders
whether it was a first-time license
application or renewal the department of
education
did not criminal background check
criminal history checked those
individuals
we used to and then in the 1990s for
some reason that was dropped and pushed
off on the districts so the statute that
has existed now for many years is that
the district is responsible for the
criminal history records check there was
legislation that passed in the last
session that tasked the department of ed
with also performing a criminal record
check for all new applicants
and that will go into effect once the
fbi authorizes us to receive the record
but that has not happened at our level
so
so your question was
what about criminal
history record checks that is performed
at the employment level by all districts
it is the law
and the department of education is
phasing back in performing it on
licensees
uh so the law went into effect january
1st however the fbi has not given
department of safety permission to
release the record to us it's imminent
we're hoping
in the next few weeks we get that record
that that approval because it's the fbi
record
right
yep follow-up
so
when that so let's pretend everything
goes as planned in
two years from now
you do you don't do you want us to
delete
well it says speech language
specialist do you should you have speech
language pathologists
in this section about licensing
no we don't believe so because again we
would be dual licensing one individual
and the feedback we have received from
the field is
practitioners do not see the need to pay
two different state agencies
for two different licenses to do the
same thing
additionally the criminal history record
check which i understand the concern
about oplc but i can assure you that the
district's by state statute also must
perform a check before that person
can be alone with a child
are
is is d.o.e going to start doing
criminal record checks on new
yes including speech with
any new any new applicant for any
endorsement that we offer
but that is strictly related to the
license not the employment
yeah one more representative
so does that mean schools will employ
speech
speech language pathologists but there
will be no
certification of those positions by the
department of ed
that would be the effect of this
legislation we would no longer certify
speech language specialists who may or
may not be a pathologist
speech language
okay we don't license speech language
pathologist today the license that
department of ed gives out is a
specialist license
which if you are a speech language
pathologist you are automatically
granted the license because you meet the
requirements
so
okay so that sounds to me like a unique
situation for people who are employed by
i'm not sure i don't know that you could
speak to that but i'm not sure i
understand that
because it's beyond it's beyond your
scope
representative lekkis
thank you um just to make sure i
understand correctly the
background checks criminal background
checks are done by the districts and are
going to be done by the doe
are going to be done for
anybody
working in the schools
and it's not tied to particular
licensing is that correct
i mean so what i'm getting at is
let's say oplc may or may not do any
kind of criminal background check for
the speech language pathologist but and
you're not going to be
licensing them
but regardless is it true that for them
to work in the school there's going to
be a background check done
yes thank you representative yes that is
correct
does any other member of the committee
have a question
is there any other member of the public
wishing to testify if you could come
two things
one it would i would prefer you bring it
up now if you could for the clerk and
the other one was the microphone but you
seem to have found that yes thank you uh
thank you mr chairman and i'll be very
brief for the record my name is tom
prasal from demers and praise all here
today representing the new hampshire
speech language hearing association
and i just wanted to address a couple
points um when this bill was initially
drafted it came from language that nisha
had provided to representative mcguire
after that was submitted to the office
of legislative services nishala has
worked with asha the american speech and
hearing association
to draft uh
language and that is the amendment that
representative marsh so kindly drafted
from ols so i think you know
everybody here would agree that we
should focus on the amendment and not
the underlying bill so i want to start
off with that and second i just wanted
to you know i think the point was raised
which is
that um there's a currently two licenses
right you know and they if you're a
speech language pathologist you're
automatically a speech language
specialist so there's no need to move
forward with the speech language
specialist license which is what what
the amendment does if you see
when you read through which i understand
most of you just got it today you'll see
it essentially phases out the speech
language specialist license
so i understand the spill is going to
sub-committee and i'm happy to work with
the committee through that process but i
was just trying to hopefully simplify i
know there's a lot of confusion between
sls slp sla a lot of that so just trying
to
you know
simplify things a bit and with that
that's all i have to say but i'm happy
to work with the committee during a
subcommittee
thank you sir does any member of the
seeing none thank you sir for your
it's up to you i'm not i'm not going to
force you to testify i'm just giving you
i know i think i've spent the whole day
lindsay courtney executive director oplc
oplc would support any legislation that
would eliminate unnecessary duplicate
licenses
i i can't testify to the board's
position on this particular legislation
but we certainly shared the initial
concerns of the bill as proposed but we
support the amendment i'd be happy to
answer any questions i know that a
question came up regarding criminal his
records history checks history records
checked
the speech language pathology board does
currently require initial applicants to
undergo criminal history records checks
so that's currently being done happy to
represent scitec
yeah i might as well go for it um
this is actually a uh
a question for
is mr applebee's still here oh there he
is uh
you said you're waiting for the fbi to
check
uh to to release how come the local
school district could do a background
check but the department of education
has to wait for the fbi to do something
thank you for the question
representative
the fbi is very particular about their
approvals for release of their records
around criminal history checks so they
must approve all legislative changes
so there is already in our statutes
enabling legislation that the fbi is
approved for school districts
but that language did not exist for the
doe to receive the record
so that's what we're waiting on
well with that if uh if anybody else
from the committee has any questions
seeing none i will close the public
you